chers collègues je vous propose de
continuer nos travaux puisque nous
étions ce matin réunis pour voter
et pour la validation de Madame Schwarz
à la tête de Météo
France on vous partagera les les
résultats si les collègues n'ont pas
forcément reçu n'hésitez pas à nous
poser la question nous auditionnons donc
cet après-midi monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
sur les crédits de la transition
écologique dans le projet de loi de
finances monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup d'avoir acceptter de venir
devant cette commission pour cette je
dirais cette audition traditionnelle sur
le budget pour votre information nous
auditionnerons monsieur Clément bonne le
ministre délégué chargé des transports
pour évoquer plus particulièrement les
sujets de mobilité mardi
prochain à noter que notre commission a
déjà s'est déjà saisie de la première
partie du budget notamment grâce aux
travaux que nous avons mené lundi soir
et mardi jusqu'au petit matin sur la
première partie du projet de loi de
finance et nous espérons bien entendu
que ce qui a été voté pourra être repris
dans ce projet de loi de finance en
particulier lors de l'examen en
commission des
finances noter aussi que ce projet loi
de finances il faut le noter et
ambitieux sur le plan de l'écologie
monsieur le ministre et il serait
important que vous puissiez nous
partager et bien l'ambition qui est la
votre notamment sur le
sujet des sujets aussi importants que le
déploiement du budget vert vous savez
que c'est un sujet qui me tient à cœur
une volonté aussi parce que que au-delà
des moyens et vous l'avez souvent
rappelé il y a la mise en œuvre de ces
60 milliards d'euros notamment à travers
de ce que j'appelle moi des serviteurs
de l'État des agents de l'État du
ministère de la transition écologique
qui dans les territoires en lien aussi
avec les collectivités territoriales
font vivre ce budget et je crois que en
la matière vous avez de bonnes nouvelles
à nous annoncer notamment sur le nombre
de TP supplémentaires dans le casadre de
ce
budget un point aussi à
noter en lien aussi avec la manière avec
laquelle vous voulez déployer ces bonnes
nouvelles budgétaires le sujet annoncé
des cops régional puisque votre volonté
est d'aller dans les territoires pour
assurer le financement de ces mesures et
leur mise en œuvre sur le terin sur le
terrain dans des délais rapprochés donc
il serait intéressant que vous puissiez
nous par partager votre volonté en la
matière pour décliner localement cette
stratégie nationale voilà monsieur le
ministre pour résumer votre ambition
peut-être nous partager donc votre
ambition sur ce budget les bonnes
nouvelles sur notamment les ETP la
manière avec laquelle vous allez
décliner ça dans les territoires je vous
laisse la parole pour une dizaine de
minutes et puis les orateurs de groupe
auront l'occasion de s'exprimer merci
Monsieur le Ministre merci monsieur le
Président cher Jean-Marc zouisi Mesdames
et Messieurs les les députés je suis
très heureux de me retrouver presque
dans une dans pas une nouvelle
commission mais en tout cas une nouvelle
salle après avoir passé un peu de temps
ici à discuter en particulier de zéro
artificialisation net mais pas seulement
euh avant le avant l'été effectivement
un exercice différent cet après-midi qui
consiste à vous présenter le budget sa
cohérence avec la planification
écologique je vais tout de suite prendre
une ou deux
précautions le le champ ministériel que
j'ai l'honneur de représenter qui va de
la cohésion des territoires à la
transition écologique passe par un
certain nombre de ministres délégués
dont certains que vous aurez l'occasion
d'auditionner et donc je serai sans
doute elliptique sur des questions de
transport de
logement de façon à ne pas faire de
redit par rapport à ce que vous avez
prévu d'accueillir pour essayer de me
concentrer à la fois sur la vision
globale et pour répondre s'il y avait
des question connexe entre transition
écologique et cohésion des territoires
puisque vous l'avez dit un des sujets
désormais c'est la territorialisation de
la planification écologique et à vrai
dire sa déclinaison et son
opérationnalisation qui va se poser en
terme de question et donc c'est cette
jointure entre d'un côté les
collectivités et de l'autre l'état y
compris pour arriver à la somme de
financement nécessaire qui pointé dans
le rapport pisaniférie mais pas
seulement je pense au chiffrage de high
forc ou d'autres repose sur une
mobilisation complémentaire de la part
des collectivités territoriales et donc
sur un effet de levier de la part de
l'État pour qu'on puisse atteindre ces
sommes et ces
niveaux quelques mots très rapide 2023
il y avait une nouveauté importante qui
était la création du fond vert avec les
2 milliards d'euros qui avaient été
annoncé cette année 2024 elle est
évidemment beaucoup plus ambitieuse à la
fois en terme de
montant en terme de d'objet en terme de
domaines dans lesquels il y a des
accélérations budgétaires je reviendrai
peut-être un peu plus tard sur les trois
questions que vous m'avez posé je vais
déjà y revenir pour partie dans la
manière dont je vais vous
répondre 10 milliards d'euros c'est le
montant
des autorisations d'engagement
complémentair au titre de la
planification écologique je vous ferai
pas l'injure même si vous n'êtes pas
commissaire aux finances de distinguer
les crédits de paiement des
autorisations d'engagement mais il me
semble à partir du moment où on parle de
planification écologique que ce qui
compte c'est bien le niveau des
autorisations d'engagement puisque par
définition en particulier dans le
domaine ferroviaire le sujet c'est pas
seulement ce qu'on décaisse dans l'année
puisqu'on a l'obligation d'attendre de
service fait pour pouvoir décaisser les
crédits c'est bien ce qu'on autorise et
ce qu'on lance y compris pour le rendre
possible et ce chiffre il est de 10
milliards dans ces 10 milliards il y a 7
milliards d'euros de crédit de paiement
et dans les 10 milliards d'euros
d'engagement d'autorisation d'engagement
il y en a SEP qui concernent le pôle
ministériel dont j'ai la responsabilité
et trois qui sont à l'extérieur un qu'on
retrouve au masa principalement sur les
questions forestières pour lequel la
tutelle est au ministère de
l'Agriculture même s'il y a beaucoup de
sujets sur lesquels nous travaillons
ensemble il y a un milliard et demi qui
s'ajoute et qui est spécifiquement sur
la partie industrie verte et il y a 600
millions pour la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments de l'état où la somme
était de 100 millions cette année et qui
marche une première marche qui marque
une première marche sur le chantier
global de la rénovation qu' ne faut pas
regarder en regardant que les logements
privés mais en regardant le patrimoine
tertiaire de l'État et des collectivités
territoriales et quand on additionne ces
différents chiffres on voit à quel point
l'accélération des crédits est
importante une fois que j'ai donné ces
grands éléments budgétaires ça veut dire
que globalement dans ce pôle ministériel
de la transition écologique c'est 15 %
de progression des crédits et 62
milliards d'euros qui sont inscrits et
là je parle bien en crédit de
paiement la nouveauté des nouveautés si
j'ose dire c'est sur les
effectifs ce pôle ministériel depuis 20
ans quelle que soit la couleur politique
de ceux qui en assumaient la
responsabilité la droite la gauche les
écologistes rendaient tous les ans des
postes de façon d'ailleurs assez
constante
avec des centaines de postes tous les
ans et un peu moins de 20000 postes qui
ont été rendus à l'échelle de ce pôle
global certains au titre de politique de
décentralisation d'autres au titre de
RGPP de réduction de nonremplacement de
départ et cetera l'année dernière pour
la première fois depuis 20 ans nous
avons eu la stabilité globale avec
quelques hausses je pense à Météo France
je pense à l'ofb je pense à l'ONF avec à
l'inverse quelques baisses de l'autre
côté
pour l'année qui arrive ce sont 760
postes nouveaux qui vont être créés à
l'échelle de ce pôle ministériel ces 760
postes ils se divisent en environ 300
chez les opérateurs d'abord la dem mais
juste ensuite les agences de l'eau de
façon assez cohérente conttenu des
enjeux que nous avons sur l'eau on peut
pas augmenter les moyens de ces agences
regarder les sujets de sécheresse et ne
pas faire en sorte de renforcer les
effectifs de ceux qui sont en première
ligne pour accompagner la lutte contre
les fuites et l'ensemble des dispositifs
qui ont été présentés à Savine leelac
dans lequel du plan haut mais il y en a
également pour le Conservatoire du
littoral pour Météo France pour l'ofb de
manière à pouvoir suivre une partie des
politiques et à côté de ces 315 postes
qui sont créés chez les opérateurs il y
en a 25 qui sont créés à la DGAC dans le
cadre des trajectoires spécifiques sur
les contrôleurs aériens qui dépendent
d'un budget annexe mais qui sont
néanmoins dans le périmètre ministériel
et le reste au niveau des services du
ministère une centaine de façon
spécifique pour l'accompagnement à la
ruralité et aux élus locaux dans les Pol
territoriale de transition écologique au
sens large le reste avec un effort
particulier au niveau de la rénovation
mais pas seulement également au niveau
des ICPE où ce sont près de 100 postes
qui sont créés sur la surveillance des
installations
classées une fois qu'on a évoqué à la
fois cette grande masse d'un point de
vue budgétaire qu'on a évoqué ensuite
cette grande masse sur le plan des
effectif quelques zoom rapide si vous
voulez
bien la plan signication écologique
présenté il y a quelques semaines et qui
explique comment nous allons tenir nos
engagements climatiques en 2030 les
gisements dans lesquels il y a des
baisses elles reposent sur 52 leviers
d'action divers tous ne nécessitent pas
un engagement budgétaire et tous ne
reposent pas d'ailleurs uniquement sur
des engagements de l'État un certain
nombre relèv d'entreprise peuvent
relever d'efforts de particuliers
peuvent relever de réallocation de
crédit et C néanmoins on a à côté de ça
le rapport pisaniférie qui chiffre un
besoin global à 68 milliards sur ces 68
milliards on considère qu'il y en a une
trentaine qui relève de la sphère
publique je parle bien de crédits
nouveaux pas des éventuelles
réorientations et dans la sphère
publique on peut avoir éventuellement
des débats mais la part de l'État elle
varie aux alentours de 15 à 20 milliards
d'euros en considérant qu'il a ensuite
une part de compléments à l'échelle des
collectivité territoriale je pars du
principe qu'on est plutôt sur la
fourchette à 20 milliards pour la partie
état pour se dire les de manière claire
au passage le fond vert avec 2 milliards
d'euros a généré 10 milliards d'euros
d'investissement à l'échelle des
collectivité territoriale l'effet de
levier mécanique sur le 1 pour 4 tel
qu'il a été constaté il est sur la base
des 17000 dossierers déposé un grand
nombre finit par baisser la probabilité
d'erreur statistique et sur 17000
dossiers quand vous avez un effet de
levier constant qui est de cet ordre là
ça vous permet sans trop faire d'erreur
de bien voir com comment les choses
peuvent se passer donc qu'est-ce que
nous faisons de cet argent d'abord on
augmente précisément le fond vert qui
passe de 2 milliards à 2 milliards et
demi en vrai c'est même un petit peu
plus que ça puisque une part du fond
vert de l'année 2023 pour les plus
avertis était la compensation de la CVAE
le delta de compensation de CVAE sur la
dernière moyenne triénale or par
définition ça disparaît comp tenu du
remplacement progressif par la TVA et
pourtant le fond passe de 2 à 2 et demi
ce qui veut dire que la part permettant
d'aller accompagner des projets sur les
territoires augmente de 40
%. je répondrai ensuite sur les
questions de modalité l'essentiel du
delta on souhaite le flécher sur la
rénovation des bâtiments des
collectivités territoriales s'il y a des
questions j'y reviendrai en particulier
avec un plan spécifique sur les écoles
qui fait l'objet d'un complément et d'un
bouquet de financement et compris avec
le nouveau dispositif et du Renov de la
Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation qui a
été présenté il y a quelques semaines à
la MF deuxième grand volet c'est
précisément cette question globale de la
rénovation énergétique
1,6 milliard d'euros de crédit nouveaux
demain devant le Congrès de l'ANA le
ministre délégé au logement détaillera
une partie des éléments nouveaux en
terme de barem même si certaines choses
sont techniques je me tiens à votre
disposition pour rentrer dans le détail
retenez un objectif passez à une moyenne
de 200000 rénovations performantes
contre les 65000 des deux premières
années de mise en service rester sur
700000 Renault global de toute façon les
chiffres tels qu'ils ont été fixés mais
faire en sorte que la part des
rénovations performantes atteignne les
200000 et pour ça c'est le déploiement
de mon accompagnateur Renov je serai
votre disposition un peu plus tard au
moment des questions
ensuite c'est la question des mobilités
et c'est 1,6 milliards complémentaires
qui sont mis globalement dans le soutien
aux mobilités toujours en autorisation
d'engagement ces crédits sont très
largement fléché vers le ferroviaire
dans le cadre des différents dispositifs
de soutien qui ont été évoqués et puis
il y a des évolutions en ce qui concerne
la voiture et notamment la voiture
électrique avec des évolutions et sur le
bonus et sur le malus et la mise en
œuvre dans le courant du mois de
novembre du dispositif de leasing qui
pour la première fois s'appuiera sur des
voitures uniquement construites en
Europe puisque on prendra compte on
tiendra compte de leur empreinte globale
et donc dans leur cycle de vie pas
seulement de leur bienfait en terme de
motorisation mais de l'endroit où elles
sont produites de façon à valor
les énergies décarbonées qui auront
servi à les
produire bien sûr reconduction du Plan
Vélo les crédits globaux sur le
verdissement de l'automobile atteindront
le milliard et demi d'euros au global un
demi mililliard de complément pour les
agences de l'eau avec un principe qui
sera à la fois de renforcer le
financement de ceux qui prélèvent et le
financement de ceux qui polluent je me
tiens à votre disposition là aussi sur
le détail de cette réforme de la
fiscalité qui est dans le PLF et les 475
millions qui correspondent précisément à
l'engagement pris à Savine leelc le 30
mars dernier laasnb la stratégie
nationale de biodiversité qui doit pas
être l'angle mort de notre transition
écologique et pour lequel ce sont 400
millions d'euros là aussi qui sont mis
en complément ça représente un
doublement des crédits affectés à la
biodiversité ça se décompose en deux
parties une qui est à destination du
monde
rural qui est une petite révolution
parce que elle elle accompagne
intellectuellement aussi loszan et la
préservation de nos espaces elle
consiste à faire en sorte que une partie
des dotations adressées aux
collectivités ne repose pas seulement
sur le nombre d'habitants mais sur la
préservation des aménités rurales et
c'est ce sont 60 millions d'euros
j'allais dire en entrée de jeu cette
année qui sont mis dans le dispositif
contre zéro dit autrement on peut
considérer que la dotation biodiversité
passe de 40 à 100 mais très concrètement
c'est bien là aussi une première marche
enfin nous reconduisons des crédits à
des hauteurs historiques sur l'économie
circulaire nous augmentons de 300
millions d'euros le fond chaleur de la
dem compte tenu de son succès et vous
avez globalement et en très rapide le
panorama de tout ça en deux mots il me
semble avoir rapidement dit ce quiétait
l'impact du fond vert est-ce qu'il était
capable de faire et s'il y a des
questions j'y répondrai de manière plus
précise je vous ai dit un mot des
effectifs enfin le président m'a
interrogé sur les copes
régionales sans être
trop techno je l'espère euh la
philosophie elle est la suivante la
planification par définition ça suppose
de changer d'optique et de logique pour
se dire les choses de manière un peu
près simple dans la quasittalité des
pays du monde et le notre n'y a pas fait
exception on constate au début de
l'année ou en milieu d'année quand on a
les chiffres consolidés sur les
émissions de l'année précédente où nous
en sommes exactement là on explique où
on va aller et quelles sont les baisses
qu'on espère année par année et surtout
comment on compte les
obtenir ce dispositif il suppose de
planifier donc d'accompagner en amont ou
par de la réglementation ou par du
budget ou par de la fiscalité ou par des
évolutions techniques ou des innovations
la façon dont les choses vont se passer
mais l'État a une part mais les
collectivités on on une énorme également
il y a même si c'est pas le plus gros
gisement un petit bout qui concerne les
déchets sur lequel on sait que la
politique est gérée sur le plan local
quand on discute de la façon de déployer
une politique de biodiversité ou
d'évolution sur la ressource en eau on
sait que la main elle est là aussi
auprès du local sur lesmobilités dans
beaucoup de cas ça n'est pas seulement
le montant d'un plan vélo national qui
vous permet de gagner des parts de
marché c'est la l'existence de pistyclab
sécurisé qui donne ensuite envie de
prendre son vélo même si on a été aidé à
l'acquérir c'est la complémentarité
entre les régions et l'État sur les
politiques ferroviaires dans un certain
nombre de cas c'est c'est l'existence de
bornes physique sur le domaine communal
de recharge pour accompagner une
politique de verdissement et une
politique industrielle ou de soutien et
donc quand j'additionne ces différents
éléments j'ai besoin de faire en sorte
que le tuyau du National et les tuyaux
du local aillent ensemble le dispositif
il est donc celui d'utiliser l'échelon
régional comme l'échelon de stratégie
sur le déploiement de ces gisements de
baisse pour ensuite descendre vers le
bloc commun et faire en sorte que nous
puissions utiliser les crte pour en
faire des contrats de réussite de la
transition écologique avec un changement
par rapport à la manière dont ils ont
été conçus c'est le fait qu'en face des
projets nous puissions mettre les
financements qui permettront d'atteindre
les objectifs tels qu'ils seront fixés
dans le cadre de ces échanges qui vont
se prolonger jusqu'à l'été prochain
pardon d'avoir été très succin forcément
elliptique mais vu la largeur du champ
et le temps qui m'a été donné je pouvais
difficilement descendre davantage dans
le détail je suis impatient de pouvoir
le faire à la lumière des questions que
vous déciderez de me
poser merci monsieur le ministre pour ce
propos introductif nons donc aux
orateurs des groupes et pour le groupe
Renaissance la parole est à Anthony
Bros monsieur le ministre le budget que
nous avons examiné pour 2024 est un
budget ambitieux comme si justement
indiqué par notre président zulési
ambitieux sur ses financements notamment
sur le plan climatique avec une
enveloppe de 10 milliards d'euros en
faveur de la planification écologique
inédit il doit per permettre à notre
pays d'atteindre progressivement la
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2050 sur
ces 10 milliards d'euros 7 seront
mobilisables par les ministère concerné
que ce soit pour le financement des r
métropolitains à hauteur de 700 millions
d'euros pour anticiper le leasing de
véhicules électriques à 100 € par mois
pour le fond chaleur en augmentation de
300 millions d'euros ou encore pour le
fond vert pérennisé et en augmentation
de 500 millions d'euros pour atteindre
les 2,5 milliards afin de notamment
permettre à nos collectivités de rénover
leurs écoles comme comme vous l'avez
indiqué afin de mieux préserver notre
ressource en eau et répondre aux
engagements formulés par le Président de
la République dans le cadre du Plan eau
le projet de loi de finance pour 2024 va
également permettre d'augmenter les
ressources des agences de l'eau de près
de 500 millions d'euros soit une hausse
de plus de 20 %. sobriété optimisation
de la ressource et restauration de la
qualité ces trois objectifs doi nous
permettre de réduire de 10 % nos
prélèvements d'eau de mieux détecter
réparer les fuites et de valoriser les
eau non conventionnelles mais aussi de
mieux prévenir les pollutions dans les
air de captage les attentes sur ces
aires de captage au regard de ces
dépaulements phytosanitaires ou encore
sur le plan haut et assaainissement dans
les Territoires ultra marin sont
prignantes et parfois
urgentes sur ce sujet monsieur le
ministre et alors que le plan haut a fêé
ces 6 mois pouvez-vous nous indiquer le
bilan que vous en avez tiré si des
ajustements budgétaires sont à prévoir
afin d'atteindre les objectifs que nous
nous sommes collectivement fixés et si
la trajectoire que nous visons pour 2030
sera atteinte je vous remercie merci
pour le groupe rassemble national la
parole est à Nicolas
dragon merci monsieur le Président zou
monsieur le ministre Béchu mes chers
collègues ce budget qui nous est
présenté à la particularité de compter
une augmentation de 7 milliards d'euros
en crédit de paiement pour accélérer la
transition écologique si la finalité
visée ici ne peut-être que louée il
semble nécessaire de rappeler une
évidence il ne suffit pas de débloquer
des fonds de prendre sa chaise et sauter
partout comme un cabri en criant
transition écologique réussie pour
qu'elle le soit
car oui on peut mettre autant d'argent
que l'on veut dans un projet si les
investissements et les moyens choisis
pour y parvenir ne sont pas les bons
alors ce projet n'atteindra pas la cible
voulue si ce budget se veut soi-disant
écologique on observe que très peu est
fait pour favoriser le nucléaire rien
n'est fait pour les SMR ces petits
réacteurs modulaires dont les
innovations américaines vont envahir le
marché le nucléaire est pourtant
l'énergie la plus compétitive la moins
chère et la plus décarbonée très peu
aussi pour la géothermie la BIOM mass
énergie ou encore l'hydroélectricité qui
est quand même la première source
d'électricité renouvelable en France en
revanche quand c'est pour implter encore
et toujours plus d'éolienne ces machines
infernales qui ravagent nos paysages
dévalorisent le patrimoine des Français
qui résident à proximité et ne tourne
que quand il y a du vent sur ça on peut
vous faire confiance pour préserver
notre qualité de vie pour que l'écologie
garantisse la joie de vivre des franais
et qu'elle libère notre pays de ses
dépendances extérieures il est plus que
nécessaire de mettre la transition et au
service du progrès faisons confiance en
la science encourageant la recherche et
l'innovation tournons la page de cette
écologie punitive qui tape toujours sur
les mêmes c'est-à-dire les plus faibles
pour laisser place à une écologie
positive pour tous alors Monsieur le
Ministre quand allez-vous enfin investir
dans des filières d'avenir qui sont les
seules capables de permettre la
transition écologique que vous appelez
temps de vos vœux c'était la position du
groupe rassemblement national je vous
remercie pour le groupe lafance à
soumise nupes la parole est à Gabriel
har merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre le projet de loi de finance
prévoit de porter le total des dépenses
favorables à l'environnement à 40
milliards d'euros vous augmentez donc
les budgets de 7 milliards par rapport à
l'année dernière pourtant l'Institut de
l'économie pour le climat attendait au
moins 63 milliards d'euros le budget que
vous nous présentez est donc à nouveau
insuffisant malgré la hausse et n'est
pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu climatique
je me réjouis au moins que les
mobilisations populaires autour des
enjeux écologiques vous amènent à
changer de registre vous prévoyez par
exemple une création de 10 postes pour
le serema alors que depuis 2017 394
postes ont été supprimés de même pour
mdeo France 381 postes supprimés depuis
2017 vous en créez 25 concernant les
crédits que vous prévoyez on ne
peut-être que déçus ainsi pour la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments par
exemple vous prévoyez 5 milliards
d'euros une goutte d'eau face au 25
millions de bâtiments passoir thermique
que compte la France il faudrait au
moins 50 milliards la première année
puis 100 milliards par an pendant 10 ans
sous forme de prêt sous forme de prêt
parce que le système de subvention comme
ma prime renoveve laisse au propriétaire
un reste à charge bien trop élevé et
dissuade de réaliser les travaux pour
être à la hauteur de l'enjeu climatique
il est urgent de mettre en place un
mécanisme de prêt que l'État récupère à
la mutation du bien ce dispositif a reçu
l'avis favorable des professions
concernées à l'occasion d'audition que
j'ai mené avec mon collègue coulom nous
attendons également une politique de
fret ferroviaire fondée sur
l'amélioration de l'existant et non sur
la construction d'onéreuses
infrastructures qui impactent
négativement les écosystèmes pire encore
certaines ne respectent pas les
réglementations européennes et
nationales relatives au cycle de l'eau
enfin nous vous demandons de publier
l'ensemble des bilans économiques et
sociaux pour les infrastructures de
transport réalisé conformément au code
de l'environnement afin d'apprécier les
options qui s'offrent à nous pour
l'avenir je vous remercie merci pour le
groupe les républicains la parole est à
Pierre vattan merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre la crise
qui vient en matière de logement doit
beaucoup inquiéter le gouvernement
l'interdiction de louer les passepoirs
thermiques est une folie elle a beau
être le fruit de meilleurs intention du
monde elle va réduire le nombre de
logements mis à la disposition des gens
en général les plus fragiles redoutable
ce qui s'annonce ces mots vous les aurez
reconnus ne sont pas de moi mais du
président de votre parti Édouard
Philippe ils traduisent le doute qui
commence à naître au sein de la majorité
sur la pertinence économique et en terme
d'acceptabilité de la politique de
transition écologique du gouvernement
les AFE en janvier le zan en juin la
consigne pour le plastique il y a
quelques jours avec vous on pose des
contraintes en catimini dans un texte de
loi et puis ensuite on s'arrache les
cheveux pour tenter de les faire
accepter par les Français quand ils en
prennent enfin connaissance
a priori il n'y a aucune raison pour que
ce schéma ne change avec l'usage qui
sera fait des 7 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires accordés à l'écologie en
2024 la rallonge de 1,6 milliards pour
ma prime renove alors que les rapports
se multiplient pour en dénoncer les
limites est-elle raisonnable alors que
la filière professionnelle alors alors
que ni la filière professionnelle ni les
possibilités financières des Français ne
laisse croire à un usage efficient des
crédits ainsi dégagés de même les
efforts en faveur de la voiture
électrique ont-ils jusqu'ici prouvé leur
per finance alors qu'on s'apprête à
appuyer sur
l'accélérateur le financement à long
terme de votre plan est-il seulement
assuré quand celui de 2024 repose avant
tout sur la fin du bouclier tarifaire la
suppression de quelques niches fiscales
et une contribution des collectivités
qui n'ont pas encore été consultées un
élu de terrain comme vous monsieur le
ministre devine sûrement sans oser se
l'avouer que les Français plus inquiets
de la déliquessence de leurs servicees
public et de l'explosion du prix des
carburants auraiit sans doute préféré
que leur argent serve à relancer le
nucléaire à rénover les réseaux d'au ou
à mieux entretenir les routes qui
supportent 80 % de leur déplacement
votre politique de planification
écologique qui est en réalité une
décarbonation à marche forcé qui
accélérera la crise du logement notre
perte de souveraineté énergétique et la
et la désindustrialisation
correspond-elle vraiment aux analyses de
bon sens que vous n'auriez pas manqué de
faire avant votre entrée au gouvernement
en un mot l'élut terrain Christophe
Béchu est-il fier de la politique mené
par le ministre Christophe Béchu je vous
remercie avant de laisser la parole à
Imy P peut-être rappeler que ce qui a
été décidé a été décidé notamment dans
cette commission donc n'a pas été décidé
en catimini bien entendu puisque tout ça
est public et il y a bien eu des débats
chers collègues pour le groupe démocrate
modem et indépendant la parole est à
Jimmy Parin merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre au nom du groupe
modem démocrate et apparenté je veux
saluer l'effort budgétaire sans
précédent en matière d'écologie mise en
œuvre par ce projet de loi de finances
pour 2024 le budget dédié à la
planification écologique va donc
atteindre 40 milliards d'EUR le
président de la République et la
première ministre ont annoncé les grands
objectifs 1 million de voitures
électriques d'ici 2027 autant de pompes
à chaleur 700 millions d'euros pour les
RER métropolitains plus 30 % du budget
dédié à la rénovation énergétique
j'espère que dans notre entourage dans
nos familles nous le verrons je remarque
et me réjouie également de la hausse du
budget dédié à la protection de la
diversité de l'eau respectivement 400 et
500 millions d'euros le climat et la
biodiversité sont étroitement liés et il
s'agit d'en oublier aucun
ce gouvernement au côté de sa majorité a
beaucoup fait pour la transition
énergétique avec les lois mobilité AGC
climat énergie renouvelable à nous de
les faire appliquer à nous aussi d'aller
l'expliquer dans les territoires c'est
pourquoi je veux aussi saluer l'effort
pédagogique pour l'avoir vu que vous
menez dans le cadre de votre tour de
France de la planification écologique je
conclurai en ayant un mot sur un sujet
que vous connaissez maintenant par cœur
Monsieur le Ministre l'importance de
renforcer notre présence scientifique au
pôle en vue du premier sommet
international qui se tiendra à Paris
dans un mois nous souhaitons que la
France se dote d'une loi de
programmation polaire pour planifier
dans la durée de notre réinvestissement
dans les pôles région où se joue notre
avenir je me permets simplement
d'insister sur un point le sujet ne
concerne pas uniquement le Ministère de
la Recherche je plaide donc pour que les
autres ministères concernés vous la
mèire l'outremèire la diplomatie de la
défense participe également à cette
ambition budgétaire je vous
remercie merci pour le groupe socialiste
et apparenté la parole est à Gérard le
seul merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
disons d'abord clairement les choses il
est très difficile d'évaluer précisément
et clairement les crédits dédiés à la
transition écologique et à
l'investissement qui est associé la
communication du gouvernement de cette
année consiste à expliquer qu'avec 7
milliards d'euros supplémentaires
mobilisé sur la mission écologie pour
2024 l'effort serait considérable mais
nous sommes très loin très loin des 30
milliards d'investissements
supplémentaires publics évoqués dans le
rapport pisaniferie qui évalue les
besoins d'investissement annuels pour la
transition à 68 milliards annuels moitié
privé moitié publique avec le budget
vert et la comptabilisation des crédits
favorables à l'environnement alors avec
votre exposé précédent nous sommes loin
encore très loin d'un grand Big Bang
budgétaire et fiscal à la hauteur du
défi climatique qui est devant nous nous
sommes loin par ailleurs aussi d'un
budget vert la première raison est
souligné par la Cour des
comptes qui considère que le budget vert
est trop embryonnaire seul 10 % des
dépenses budgétaires de l'État sont
aujourd'hui côtés comme ayant un impact
favorable ou défavorable d'ailleurs sur
l'environnement près de 3/4 des dépenses
sont côté comme ayant un impact neutre
l'impact environnemental des autres
dépenses étant non côé un si faible
niveau de cotation des dépenses ayant
des effets environnementaux non nul
interroge sur la complétude du document
et son caractère opérationnel pour les
décideurs publics à cour terme vous nous
avez indiqué tout à l'heure quelques
crédits supplémentaires obtenus pour
créer des des postes 760 je sais pas si
ce sont des etotp mais dans les
différents ministères comme dans les
agences qui qui en dépendent c'est un
effort mais je rappelle que ça ne
compense pas les suppressions que vos
gouvernement ont réalisé depuis 2017 500
postes supprimés chez méto France 100
postes supprimés au serema plus de 500
postes supprimés chez l'ONF depuis 2017
enfin je suis inquiet de constater que
les crédits annoncés ne sont pas en
phase avec les planans par votre
gouvernement ces derniers mois où en
est-on du plan de 100 milliards annoncé
par la première ministre pour le
ferroviaire voilà nous avons besoin de
visibilité de projection d'ambition de
son côté le gouvernement a besoin de
crédibilité pour une véritable
planification écologique la crédibilité
signifierait à la fois crédit
supplémentairire et confiance ce budget
ne mobilise ni l'un ni l'autre merci
pour le horizon et apparenté la parole
est à Anne Cécile
violent merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
tout d'abord je tiens tiens à vous
remercier d'être présent monsieur le
ministre aujourd'hui pour répondre à nos
questions et je tiens au nom du groupe
horizon et apparentier à vous remercier
pour l'augmentation conséquente de ce
budget mais aussi la mise en place de
mesures en faveur de mobilité verte et
plus particulièrement en faveur du
signal prix pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone il était temps d'agir comme le
mentionne le rapport de février dernier
du Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures investir plus et mieux
dans lesmobilités pour réussir leur
transition la neutralité carbone
nécessite aussi d'actionner de leviers
complémentaires de sobriété qui implique
report modal et développement des
transports collectifs et massification
du fret je vous avais d'ailleurs
sollicité en avril sur un sujet
similaire concernant l'impact de la
sortie des énergies fossiles sur
l'inflation et le pouvoir d'achat dans
l'objectif de faire progresser la
fiscalité environnementale je me réjouis
donc de constater que dans l'article 15
du projet de loi de finance pour 2024
vous prévoyez de renforcer la logique du
signal prix mais aussi dans le domaine
des transports de l'agriculture et de
l'énergie
monsieur le ministre le groupe horizon
défend la démarche du signal prix et ne
peut que la saluer car nous savons qu'il
s'agit là d'un véritaable enjeu
environnemental et social au-delà du
secteur des transports l'Union
européenne a abouti il y a peu à un
accord pour accérer la sortie des gaz
fluoré dit HFC en vue de leur
élimination d'ici
2050 la législation française prévoit à
ce jour de faire débuter en 2025 une
taxe progressive sur ses gaz à 15 € la
tonne équivalent CO2 qui monterait
progressivement en puissance pour
atteindre 30 € en 2029 que pensez-vous
de la perspective d'avancer cette date à
2024 et avec un taux intermédiaire qui
pourrait concourir à inciter le secteur
à réduire plus rapidement ses émissions
en rendant les alternatives bas carbon
plus compétitives plus largement
pourriez-vous nous indiquer comment nous
pouvons vous aider à renforcer la
logique de ce signal prix afin de faire
avancer l'ambition du PLF sur ces
questions je vous remercie merci merci
beaucoup nous continuons avec le groupe
écologiste nupes et la parole est à
Marie Bechon merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre mardi 26 septembre
dernier avec mon groupe des écologistes
nous rappelions au gouvernement
l'urgence du dérèglement climatique avec
l'illustration des warming Stripes elle
montre la vitesse de l'augmentation des
températures au cours des siècles en
réponse monsieur le ministre vous nous
avez reproché de je vous cite ne pas
parler du fond et de et nos postures
sans nuance les warming strip ne sont
pas une posture encore moins une opinion
mais bien l'expression d'un fait
scientifique celui des changements
climatiques qui bouleverse notre monde
puisqu'il conditionne l'habitabilité de
la terre mais également un fait
éminemment politique celui de la
contribution reconnu des activités
humaines à celui-ci et donc des choix
politiques que nous faisons ou pas pour
les orienter je réponds donc à votre
invitation pas de posture mais de
l'ouverture et voilà quelques
propositions de bon sens que nous vous
soumettons le Haut Conseil pour le
climat nous le répét il y a quelques
jours pour avoir plus qu'un budget vert
embryonnaire il nous faut sortir des
dépenses néfastes au climat nous
proposons donc d'accélérer sur ce sujet
et de mettre fin à certaines niches
incompréhensibles pour les Français
comme la niche kérosè du secteur aérien
qui subventionne la mobilité des plus
riches alors même que temps galèrent
avec leurs bagnoles ou des transports
publics trop cher une autre proposition
simple et basique sur laquelle j'espère
que nous pourrons avancer ensemble la
protection des forêts et de leur puit de
carbone divisé par 2 ces 10 dernières
années via le conditionnement des aides
publiques à la bonne gestion forestière
et le renforcement des moyens de l'ONF
enfin nous ferons plusieurs propositions
pour soutenir les agriculteurs en bio
qui sont en grande difficulté il n'est
pas normal que ceux-ci soi moins soutenu
par l'argent public que ceux qui font
moins d'effort aussi nous vous proposons
des fonds d'urgence pour aider la bio au
moins pour empêcher les déconversions
l'argent est là mais il part
actuellement dans des impasses comme le
label HVE nous avons bien sûr d'autres
proposition renforcement du malus poid
écocontribution sur les billets d'avion
euh taxes sur le les PI fe mais le temps
me manque pour les porter toutes ici
j'en viens donc à ma question pour
sortir des postures et montrer votre
ouverture à votre tour seriez-vous prêt
monsieur le ministre à reprendre toute
ou au moins une de ces propositions dans
le cadre du projet de loi de finance je
vous remercie merci pour le groupe
liberté indépendant outreem et
territoire la parole est à Jean-Louis
bricou merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues les
enjeux climatiques engagent notre
responsabilité à toutes et tous je
dirais même que vu l'urgence et les
retards les volontarismes doivent
s'affirmer c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur le ministre vous évoquez un
budget qui serait le plus vert de notre
histoire 40 milliards d'euros mais pour
autant l'épisode budgétaire doit passer
par des compromis et des consensus pour
le rendre certainement plus ambitieux
nous les cas nous y sommes prêts malgré
quelquefois la et même souvent la menace
du 493 monsieur le ministre il faut
sanctuiriser les enveloppes nécessaires
à une vraie transition écologique faute
de temps mes questions seront centrées
sur la rénovation énergétique éque des
bâtiments des propositions concrètes qui
émanent du rapport que nous avons
présenté la semaine dernière avec mes
collègues Julie la hernos et margeline
menmil faire nos propositions sont sur
la table massifier les rénovations
globales et performantes est
incontournable on en convient tous je
crois il y a les moyens mais il y a
aussi la méthode mon accompagnateur
renove va monter en puissance quelle
place entendez-vous lui dédier dans le
parcours de rénovation quels seront les
moyens humains sur les territoires et à
quelle échéance quelle évolution dans
ces compétences et puis quelle dynamique
peut-il créer aussi avec les
collectivités territoriales sur les
enjeux de rénovation par quartier de
réseau de chaleur en de massification en
fin de compte des
rénovations sur sur la question des
moyens financiers les bailleurs sociaux
vont bénéficier d'une enveloppe
supplémentaire d'un milliard 2 sur 3 ans
pour les rénovations s'agit-il d'une
ligne budgétaire supplémentaire ou
entamera-t-il la ligne de ma prime renve
j'is voir la confirmation le reste à
charge reste un frein majeur à
l'inovation comment pensez-vous y
remédier les co PTZ et le par qui semble
être sensible aussi à mon collègue
précédent sont mal connus mal promus par
le secteur bancaire nous vous proposons
la banque de la rénovation y êtes-vous
prêt dans la recherche de nouvelles
ressources financières j'ai évoqué la
possibilité pour les que les banques
deviennent des obligés des c2ef au même
titre que les que les énergéticiens y
êtes-vous favorable enfin les
entreprises qui structurent la filière
de la rénovation énergétique ont besoin
de stabilité des dispositifs et de
visibilité êtes-vous prêt à vous engager
sur des plans pluriannuels au budget
clairement
identifiésci merci chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous avez pu avoir
la parole des orateurs des groupes je
vous laisse le soin de répondre en
sachant que vous avez d'orsé déjà une
quinzaine de
questions
d'accord parfait alors considérons que
j'ai 1 heure devant moi pour répondre à
toutes vos questions celles déjà posées
et celles qui viendront c'est pareil je
vais essayer d'être d'être ai et
j'espère ne pas trop vous frustrer je
remercie Antony Bros pour l'appréciation
globale pour le rappel de la
sobriété et pour la question qui porte
sur le bilan du plan haut la 53e mesure
du plan haut c'est de faire un bilan de
fois par an ça fait 6 mois donc le
premier bilan a été fait la semaine
dernière à Longnes dans le Pas de Calais
devant l'Association des maires de ce
département qui avait décidé de
présenter ou de faire de la gestion de
l'eau son thème 53 mesures sur les 53
mesures il y en a 12 qui sont d'ors et
déjà mis en œuvre il y en a 34 qui ont
été initié et le delta qui doivent
encore l'être mais pour lesquels la
plupart du temps le calendrier faisait
référence aux années 24 ou 25 je vous
donne un exemple parmi d'autres c'est la
question du plafond mordant des dépenses
des agences de l'eau les agences de
l'eau ont des budgets qui sont des
budgets qui fonctionnent par période
pluriannuelle et donc on ne peut changer
les règles de comptabilité qu'au début
de la prochaine période pluriannuelle
qui commencera au premier janvier 2025
donc on augmente leur crédit mais la
mécanique comptable qui permet de pas
être enfermé par les dispositifs de
plafond vous sera présentée dans le
cadre du pllf
25 qu'est-ce que je peux dire très vite
là-dessus cet automne est très important
pour la réutilisation des EAU usées je
rappelle que ça n'est pas la solution
miracle je rappelle qu'elle est
particulièrement pertinente quand on est
en bord de mer parce que ça évite
d'aller rejeter de l'eau dans la mer et
à l' à l'inverse à l'in ur des terres il
peut être souhaitable de le rejeter
malgré tout dans le milieu le 29 août le
décret pour rendre possible tous les
usages de réutilisation d'eau usé en
particulier par les collectivités
territoriales pour arroser les espaces
verts et laver les voiries a été signé
au mois d'octobre le décret est à
l'heure actuelle au Conseil d'État ce
sont les usages agroalimentaires qui
vont être rendus possiblebl et ce sont
des choses très concrètes c'est une
usine d'Anon en Normandie pour lequelle
c'est 600 millions de litres économisé
si vous signez ça de façon j'allais dire
totalement transparente pour les gens et
cetera et puis il y a la dernière partie
sur les eaux grises en particulier et
pour la partie logement sur lesquell là
on sera sans doute plus près du mois de
décembre que du mois d'octobre parce
qu'on est sur des sujets DHUP un peu
plus
complexes le plan haut c'était
l'ambition d'avoir 1000 projets
significatif de réutilisation d'eau usé
nous en avons 419 au 1er octobre qui
nous ont été remontés ce qui est très en
avance de phase cont tenu du temps dans
lequel nous trouvons et ce sont des
engagements tenus sur la mise en place
d'un dispositif pour que les gens
puissent savoir les restrictions qui
s'applique là où ils sont et cetera je
me tiens à votre disposition y compris
peut-être pour faire passer un document
qui est ce bilan d'étape à 6 mois pour
que vous ayez le temps de l'examiner de
regarder plus avant là où nous en sommes
ensuite sur où nous en sommes sur les
trajectoires de sobriété et la baisse
effective des 10 % sur les différents
territoires les 50 sites industriels
sont identifiés à eux seul c'est 25 %
pour seulement 50 sites de la
consommation industrielle d'eau qui sera
diminué parfois dans des proportions
très impressionnantes je prends juste un
cas le site àam lui aussi dans le Pas de
caletis on passe de 1800000 M C certains
le savent puisqu'il était lors de la
visite à zéro puisque c'est uniquement
la réutilisation des eau de pluie et la
réutilisation des EAU usées qui dans le
process remplace un forage et un
prélèvement dans le canal adjacent je
pourrais multiplier les exemples de typ
je pense que honnêtement ça nous
emporterait dans un schéma dans lequel
je ne vais pas entrer mais sachez que
nous sommes
dessus je veux dire à Nicolas
dragon que j'apprécie la confiance qu'il
me porte en me demandant de réagir sur
les sujets qui sont plutôt porté par
agès panier runach sur le nucléaire sur
l'hydroélectricité et sur la géothermie
et je le prends comme une marque de
confiance de sa part à mon endroit je ne
doute pas que agè P runach aura
l'occasion de préciser les choses je
vais pas me faire sa porte-parole son
porte-parole mais je peux dire que les
crédits consacrés au nucléaair
augmentent ils augmentent de 10 % que
par définition quand vous vous êtes dans
un programme de relance de l'industrie
qui effectivement nous permet d'avoir un
bon bilan carbone et de tenir nos
trajectoire et qui est un avantage
compétitif et un avantage de transition
pour notre pays le temps qu'il faut pour
relancer y compris pour déployer un
certain nombre de ces technologies prend
du temps et on est typiquement dans le
cas où les sommes qui figurent dans le
budget ne reflètent pas l'intensité de
l'effort budgétaire y compris quand vous
vous appuyez sur un opérateur national
qui a été renationalisé donc une partie
des crédits y compris des crédits de
recherche
n'apparaissent pas dans le budget de
l'État mais apparaissent dans celui de
l'opérateur qui déploie cette politique
nous avons abaissé les seuils
d'hydroélectricité les décrets seront
pris dans quelques jours on na pas été
au niveaux les plus bas parce qu'il y a
des questions de continuité agricole
dans un certain nombre de cas mais nous
avons été à des niveaux plus bas que
ceux qui existent pour tenir compte de
cette source et je crois
particulièrement au gisement de la
géothermie et en particulier la
géothermie de surface pour aller au bout
des choses l'hôtel de rocklore qui
abrite le ministère de la transition
écologique choisit là au milieu de ce
mois d'octobre l'opérateur qui va mettre
en place un système de géothermie pour
que nous puissions aussi être un
démonstrateur et montrer que nous
appliquons l'exemplarité que nous
demandons aux
autres je pense que c'est important de
pas sauter sur sa chaise comme un cabri
en parlant d'écologie
punitive et que typiquement sur un sujet
comme celui-là il faut savoir de quoi
nous parlons en clair je ne vois pas
dans le leasing pour la voiture à 100 €
dans l'augmentation des moyens qui
permettent demain d'aller rénover une
partie des logements dans le soutien la
réindustrialisation verte du pays ce qui
relève d'une forme d'écologie punitive
et nous essayons de nous garder de deux
écueils de façon simple le premier qui
consiste à laisser penser que nous ne
ferions rien et à expliquer que une
écologie qui ne serait pas
anticapitaliste ne serait pas écologiste
c'est mentir au français parce que si
nous avions un modèle antiapitaliste
dans le monde qui avait per permis de
conduire une révolution écologique ça
saurait et à l'inverse de ne pas partir
dans une optique qui consisterait de
l'autre côté à laisser penser que on en
fait trop et qu'il serait urgent de
ralentir je veux dire à Gabriel Amar qui
peut légitimement se sentir visé parce
que je viens de dire par ceux qui
considèrent que l'écologie sans la lutte
des classes c'est du jardinage c'est
avec ce genre de propos qu'on dégoûte
une partie de nos concitoyens qui refuse
de faire du greenwashing de la lut des
classes ou du combat contre les riches
et la simplicité qui consiste à dire
mais c'est simple il y a qu'à mettre 50
milliards la première année et 100
milliards la 2è année relève au mieux
d'une pensée magique et je veux croire
que vous pouvez faire mieux pour
reprendre le titre d'un ouvrage mieux
inspiré que certaines déclarations par
tweet plus récentes en ce qui concerne
les autres sujets que vous évoquez en
particulier les bilans environnementaux
qui seraient à publier je pense qu'on
gagne toujours à faire preuve de
transparence je veux vous dire dans ce
domaine que
euh vous aurez la chance d'auditionner
dans quelques
jours Clément baunne et je vous fais
confiance pour le relancer y compris
pour
pouvoir avoir des éléments par rapport à
certaines fake news qui circulent sur
les bilans environnmentaux
d'infrastructure qui vont permettre
d'enlever des dizaines de milliers de
camions et la pollution associé dans la
vallée de larve parce que quand je lis
ce que sont les conséquences y compris
hydrique et la base des rapports sur
lesquels ça s'appuie en omettant les qui
sont d'un avis différent je considère
qu'il y a une forme de manipulation dans
la façon dont on présente les choses je
veux dire à Pierre Vatin que le
Christophe Béchu que je suis
fondamentalement s'efforce de rester en
cohérence avec lui-même que c'est un
combat de tous les jours mais je crois
que c'est vrai aussi pour un député et
même pour n'importe qui qui a un peu de
sens moral parce qu'on est tous
confrontés tous les jours à des
situations dans lesquelles notre
boussole intérieure les situations face
auxquelles on est confronté nécessite
d'être capable
de continuer avant s
droit je va vous dire TR deux ou trois
choses simples le maire que j'ai été
continue de penser qu'il faut s'appuyer
sur les territoires et c'est ce qui
explique la souplesse qu'on a mis dans
le zan et accessoirement la décision que
j'ai annoncé concernant la non
généralisation de la consigne pour
continuer à faire confiance aux
collectivités territorial à Nant il y a
de cela quelques jours le maire que j'ai
été refuse qu'on instrumentalise une
partie des peurs et se réjouit d'avoir
précisé que la zdfe c'était pas un outil
qui devait consister à faire en sorte de
chasser des voitures pour le plaisir des
territoires mais il fallait lier les
interdictions au niveau de la réalité de
la pollution atmosphérique ce qui m'a
valu quelques critique pas forcément de
votre famille politique mais de d'autres
en considérant que justement je
réduisais trop le spectre et que des 43
et des feux effectifs qui allaient se
mettre en place il en resterait sans
doute que
cinq je veux dire au républicains que
vous êtes qui nous manque une chose
aujourd'hui dans le débat climatique si
on veut l'objectiver c'est le coût de
l'inaction et très concrètement dans des
quantités de domaines si on a les yeux
qui sont arrivés sur les sommes que nous
mettons et qu'on regarde pas ce qu'on va
mettre si on met pas les bonnes sommes
au bon moment on on va aller vers des
lendemains y compris d'un point de vue
budgétaire qui déchante je vous donne un
exemple simple parce qu'il fait je pense
partie des sujets qui nous
rassemblent quand vous avez une
sécheresse qui vous coûte 2,5 milliards
d'euros sur un seul été rajoutez un demi
milliard d'euros par an pour faire en
sorte d'éviter qu'ell se reproduise ça
n'est pas un cadeau c'est pas une
augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires pour le plaisir c'est une
façon y compris rationnel d'éviter
demain de se retrouver avec des coups
qui vont exploser et je peux comprendre
et c'est même le jeu de la démocratie
qu'on est des domaines dans lesquels
nous sommes en désaccord j'ai plus de
difficultés à m'imaginer que avec vous
sur la question du de la voiture
électrique nous avons des désaccords de
fond parce que je vais vous donner trois
raisons qui de mon point de vue en
souvenir des années heureuses que que
j'ai passé dans une famille politique
nous avons été ensemble devrait nous
conduire à nous retrouver du même côté
d'abord la
souveraineté arrêter d'acheter des
énergies fossiles à des pays qui sont
des dictatures qui ne partagent pas
notre vision et qui financent des
terroristes dans divers endroits de la
planète ou des guerres est un premier
sujet qui devrait nous réunir et de ce
point de vue qu'on fasse en sorte de
manière très claire d'aller vers une
énergie au contraire que nous produisons
via le nucléire et les énergies
renouvelables avec notre souveraineté
est un sur lequel je pense que forcément
on se retrouve de pour la question du
pouvoir d'achat oui une voiture
électrique c'est cher à l'achat ce que
vous économiseer si vous économisez un
plein par mois c'est 1200 € par
an d'économie sur le fonctionnement et
de ce point de vue on a là aussi un
intérêt objectif en terme de soutien et
de suivi 3 à partir du moment où on
réindustrialise sur cette base et où les
consommateurs sont sont en train de
devancer les
électeurs le taux d'immatriculation de
voiture électrique pour le mois de
septembre 19,1 % je parle pas des
hybrides je ne parle que des voitures
électriques ce chiffre il progresse tous
les mois et il progresse à l'échelle
européenne laissz penser que nous
devrions encourager nos constructeurs à
continuer à fabriquer des voitures
thermiques c'est préparer des vagues de
licenciement dans les années qui
viennent en ne les confrontant pas à la
réalité de la sit que ceux qui ont
l'habitude de regarder le passé avec
nostalgie et envie de nous y ramener je
le comprends mais que ceux qui
souhaitent à devenir pour une part
l'avenir de ce pays ne regarde pas avec
nous dans cette direction j'ai plus de
difficultés à le comprendre je veux dire
à Jimmy
pin que je garde un
souvenir ému de ce dîner partagé avec le
patron de Paul émil Victor avec
Jean-Louis Étienne et avec Valérie
massonmotte et toute une partie de nos
glaciologu en prévision de ce one polar
sumit des 9 et 10 novembre je veux dire
à quel point la loi de programmation
polaire que vous portez est importante
elle dépasse de très très loin la
question de cette seule commission la
fonte des glaces c'est la redéfinition
des espaces géopolitiques avec des
territoir majeur de conflit entre la
Chine la Russie et les États-Unis dans
les années qui viennent si on ne s'en
préoccupe pas de manière internationale
la fonte des glaces c'est le relâchement
au travers de la fonte du permafrost
potentiel pas seulement d'un péril
climatique mais de question de santé qui
peuvent également nous rattraper face à
ça pensez qu'on va chacun rester dans
nos couloirs pour aller chercher des
informations dont on a besoin alors
qu'elles auront un impact y compris sur
la montée des EAU partir sur la planète
est une folie que notre pays soit à la
fois à la hauteur de son histoire en
assurant l'entretien de ses bases et en
regardant comment écrire de nouvelles
pages de coopération en pouvant
accueillir des chercheurs étrangers dans
l'ensemble de nos espaces est
souhaitable et je me réjouis du
caractère particulièrement
transpartisant de ce que vous avez
souhaité mettre en œuvre et je peux vous
assurer de mon soutien pas seulement
pour cet événement je veux dire à Gérard
le seul que je
comprends la frustration partielle qui
est la sienne de ne pas complètement
arrivriver à retrouver les siens et ses
petits dans la construction
budgétaire je prends aussi comme un
hommage le fait qu'il considère que
notre budget vert est incet puisque nous
sommes le premier pays au monde à avoir
mis en place un budget vert ça n'est pas
moi qui le dit qui soit in complet c'est
une réalité simplement on va d'abord le
compléter après un vote MAJ de la MF en
étendant un dispositif de budget vert
aux collectivités territorial de plus de
3500 habitants et ensuite je l'invite
avec moi à ce qu'on réfléchisse en terme
de modalité quand il nous reproche qu'on
a des dépenses neutres est-ce que des
dépenses d'éducation nationale est-ce
que des dépenses régaliennes de justice
de sécurité des dépenses militaire peuv
facilement être rangé dans la case du
brun ou du
vert par définition le budget de l'État
dans le maintien d'un certain nombre de
services et de missions régaliennes ne
peut pas être 100 % ventilé entre ces
types de dépenses sauf à faire là aussi
une forme de Green wasashing en disant
que quand même on a des munitions
biodégradables et euh on a des uniformes
recyclables je je ça ne serait pas
suffisant pour qu'on prenne la totalité
du budget de l'armée et qu'on dise
regardez euh c'est vert et donc on a le
droit de le mettre dans cette catégorie
je pense que vous serez d'accord avec
moi donc on a encore des progrès de
méthodologie à faire et bien compter
c'est indispensable parce que c'est ce
qui nous permettra d'être sûr que nous
allons dans le bon sens sur les
effectifs votre cruauté Monsieur le
Commissaire aurait pu s'étendre au
mandat de François Hollande puisque la
chiffre de baisse des effectifs au titre
de l'écologie pendant les années 2017 à
2022 se sont inscrites dans la même
trajectoire que ce qui s'est passé entre
2012 et 2017 en moins important en
volume comme quoi il est parfois
important à la fois fois de ber devant
sa porte et de faire en sorte que nous
soyons dans des continuités
ensuite de manière à vous aider à être
moins fâché avec les
chiffres vous dites que
7 c'est pas beaucoup évidemment si on
compare 7 à 68 on a un problème je vais
donc une dernière fois ou plutôt une
dernière fois devant cette commission
cet après-midi rappeler ce que sont les
enjeux et inviter chacun à bien regarder
ce que dit le rapport pisaniférie le
rapport pisaniférie ne dit pas l'état
doit mettre en 2024 68 milliards d'euros
de crédit dit nouveau il dit il y a un
besoin de mobilisation qui doit
atteindre à la fin de la décennie 68
milliards dans ces 68 milliards la part
de la puissance publique doit être de 30
dans cette part qui doit être de 30 il y
a une part pour l'État une part pour les
collectivités territoriales la part de
l'État elle n'est pas de 7 elle est de
10 puisque par définition je le redis
une autorisation d'engagement est le
seul moyen d'aller engager une dépense
écologique dès lors qu'on est sur une
dépense pluri-annuelle et l'effet de
levier par rapport aux collectivités
locales fait que je peux affirmer sans
le moindre doute que c'est au moins la
moitié de cette marche à 300 qui dès la
première année du plan est sur la table
quand je dis au moins c'est à vrai dire
en dessous d'une estimation qui est
plutôt au 2 tiers quand on additionne à
la fois les crédits budgétaires
nationaux la progression des crédits
locaux comptenu des verdissements et de
la progression du fond vert et les
mesures complémentaires hors budget de
l'État mais qui sont à l'intérieur de la
sphère publique comme l'accélération de
la trajectoire de régénération autofinan
par la SNCF pour une part ou la
mobilisation de ressources propres d'une
partie de nos opérateurs un C violent
m'a posé une question alors d'abord sur
le signal prix ensuite sur les gaz
fluorés je commence par les gaz fluorés
c'est sans doute une des questions les
plus technique sur lequel il faut que je
prenne 15 secondes pour vous répondre
oui une trajectoire avec une taxe
progressive pour ces gaz fluorés qui
sont une menace pour l'environnement a
été mise en place en 2025 le
gouvernement est attaché à la à la fois
au calendrier à la mise en œuvre et au
caractère prédictif de manière on ne
souhaite pas faire rentrer de l'argent
on souhaite diminuer les usages de ces
gaz et donc l'enjeu c'est un signal prix
non pas pour obtenir des crédits mais
pour faire en sorte d'accélérer des
alternatives la difficulté c'est que dès
lors qu'il y a une législation
européenne dans un domaine il n'y a plus
de place pour une législation
nationale le début des discussions à
l'échelle européenne est une bonne
nouvelle parce que il vaudrait mieux
qu'on ait un calendrier global et
ambiteux à l'échelle européenne qu'à la
seule échelle nationale puisque'à la fin
les enjeux climatiques sont toujours
internationaux simplement
si cette logique européenne va à son
terme elle supplantera notre logique
nationale et nous avons eu la semaine
dernière un trilogue assez encourageant
sur le degré d'ambition et sur la
capacité des États européens à se mettre
d'accord dans un calendrier court sur un
dispositif analogue à celui qui a été
mis en France mais qui se passera à
l'échelle européenne on en saura un peu
plus dans les prochaines semaines et à
l'occasion des des prochains conseils
mais la volonté est intacte c'est le
cadre européen ou national pour lequel
la question se
posera je crois au signal prix
profondément je pense que le signal prix
il participe aussi à envoyer des
messages comme d'ailleurs les signaux
fiscaux comme le fait de faire en sorte
d'avoir moins de brun et plus de verre
et même idéalement dans un domaine où je
me sers des
revenus et de la fiscalité brune non pas
pour augmenter les moyens de l'État mais
pour pouvoir faire des baisse fiscale
sur ce qui est vertueux parce qu'à la
fin si on veut pas donner raison à ceux
qui dénoncent l'écologie punitive il
faut éviter que l'écologie devienne le
prétexte pour interdire et pour taxer
contaxe au nom de l'écologie c'est pour
baisser ce qui est vertueux ça me pose
pas de difficulté contaxe pour aller
compenser une partie du du trou
budgétaire ça m'empose davantage dans ce
domaine il y a encore quelques marges
d'amélioration dans la copie budgétaire
qui vous a présenté je n'en doute pas je
crois au vertu de la coconstruction je
sais les réflexions qui se font jour sur
une partie de ces B bon je me réjouis de
l'intervention de Madame pochon et de la
manière dont sur un certain nombre de
sujets elle a fait du teasing sur ce qui
pourrait être mis en place sur le
soutien à l'agriculture bio et au forêt
qui sont des sujets assez consensuels
sur lequel les éventuelles divergences
que nous avons dans d'autres domaines
euh ne nuirit pas à ce qu'il puisse y
avoir des mesures sur lesquelles nous
nous retrouvons c'est compliqué pour moi
sur la base d'une déclaration de
principe de pouvoir vous dire si
j'achète si j'achète pas et comment je
le vois sans aller dans le détail de ce
que vous proposez mais sur le principe
qui consiste à regarder comment on tire
ensemble dans la même direction vous me
trouverez toujours dans cet état
d'esprit
enfin je veux dire à gub brikou que les
crédits pour les HLM sont bien un
complément de crédit par rapport à ce
qui a été annoncé oh
pardon pardon monsieur le député
euh voilà j'ai perdu tous mes moyens
voilà
not future coopération c'est peut-être
ça bon donc écoutez non très très
concrètement HLM oui c'est bien des
crédits
nouveaux l'objectif c'est d'avoir un
rest à charge qui soit
diminuent en fonction des revenus une
des fiertés sur ma prime renove on n pas
tout réussi il y a des quantités de
choses qu'on doit améliorer une des
choses qui a été le plus réussi en
revanche c'est qu'on est passé d'une
situation en 2017 où les 2 tiers des
crédits bénéficient au 50 % les plus
riches une situation dans laquelle
aujourd'hui les 2/ers des crédits
bénéficient au 50 % les plus fragiles et
à
enveloppe très augmenté c'est assez
logique puisque en 2017 c'était un
crédit d'impôt et donc par définition
ceux qui n'en payaient pas n'en
bénéficient absolument pas dans des
proportions comparable à ceux qui en
payit beaucoup donc je me réjouis qu'on
a fait rimer cette politique écologique
et ces politiques sociales comment
est-ce qu'on va faire pour tenir nos
objectifs d'abord effectivement avec des
effectifs complémentaires c'est près de
150 personnes qui un titre ou un autre
vont renforcer les équipes de la
rénovation énergétique dont 55 à l'ANA
et d'autres en interne au niveau du
ministère mais je vais vous dire je
crois au vertuus de la décentralisation
et de la
déconcentration mon rêve ce serait sur
le modèle de la délégation des aides à
la pierre on puisse responsabiliser les
collectivités territoriales avec des
objectifs si es n'atteignent pas cet
objectif l'État continue à les assumer
si elle les atteignent elle bénéficie
des délégations de crédit pour les
mettre en œuvre qu'est-ce que j'en
attends la proximité et la fiabilité du
processus j'ai la faiblesse de penser
que quand vous confiez à une
intercommunalité une compétence de ce
type elle va utiliser ses mairies
annexes ses espaces son journal
municipal pour faire savoir que le
dispositif existe elle va sensibiliser
sa chambre des métiers ou sa chambre des
commerces pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait des gens qui s'engagent dans ce type
de dispositif elle va valoriser des
artisans de proximité et elle rendra
possible une accélération aussi de ces
différents éléments enfin le reste à
charge il est diminuant c'est ce que je
vous disais avec le niveau de revenu on
souhaite qu'il soit de zéro pour les
plus fragiles au titre de
l'accompagnement et le niveau global euh
des subventions peut dans les cas les
plus important monter jusqu'à 90 % pour
à la fois les foyers les plus fragiles
et également les bons de performance
énergétique les plus importants puisque
c'est cette performance énergétique
qu'on souhaite valoriser avec une sorte
de prime pour la sortie des passoirs je
terminerai uniquement par ce sujet en
une
minute parce que je réalise que j'ai
oublié c'est un acte manqué peut-être
psychanalytique de répondre à la
déclaration faite par le président d'un
parti qui m'est cher je pense que
d'opposer la crise du logement et
l'urgence climatique est une fausse
bonne idée et je vais aller plus loin je
vous crois sincère monsieur le député
quand vous dites que il faut qu'on pense
au plus modeste et je ve crois que c'est
le cas de tout le monde
ici une passoire thermique c'est aussi
une passeoire budgétaire pour celui qui
l'habite
et il y a des locataires dans ces
passoirs se préoccuper de comment les
propriétaires font les
travaux je le comprends qu'on se
préoccupe de comment les locataires de
ces passeports payent leur charges je
souhaiterais qu'on le fasse aussi
puisque c'est objectivé je vous donne un
chiffre un logement de 75 m² class g
c'est une moyenne de facture énergétique
de 4000 € le même logement s'il est
classé d c'est en moyenne 2000 € de
charge vous avez un écart de 2000 € par
an sur la facture énergétique du
locataire qui est à l'intérieur on voit
bien que si on est habité par l'urgence
sociale que vous décrivez on a la
nécessité de se préoccuper de ça ensuite
je vais plus loin parce qu'il circule
beaucoup de fake news sur le sujet le
1er janvier 2025 on va sortir aucun
locataire personne n'a dit ça ça c'est
c'est ça n'existe pas où sont les
sorties des
G+ si il y avait une bombe à venir on
devrait avoir constaté sur euh les
150000 logements insalues de ce 1er
janvier quelque chose la réalité des
chiffres elle est la suivante
1 les passepoirs thermiques sont plus
souvent qu'en moyenne presque deux fois
plus des logements vacants et donc aider
les propriétaires à faire les travaux
c'est parfois les aider à trouver un
locataire parce qu'une partie de ces
logements sont vacants parce que les
locataires ne veulent pas aller dedans
comp tenu du fait que l'air passe sous
les fenêtres ou qu'il n'y a pas de
capacité d'isolation
de évidemment les propriétaires
occupants ne sont pas concernés
un nombre important de ces passoirs ce
sont des résidences secondaires dans une
proportion qui est supérieure aux
résidences principales et donc qui elle
aussi ne sont pas concernés malgré les
chiffres qu'on donne par cette
obligation de travaux pour continuer à
bénéficier d'une location enfin le geste
le plus simple c'est de passer de G
F même si l'objectif est de
favoriser de façon très claire des
rénovations performantes nous allons
valoriser le geste qui consiste de
passer de GF en montrant le peu qu'il
coûte de manière à sécuriser le fait
qu'un propriétaire qui voudrait
continuer à louer puisse le faire dans
des conditions simples et un coût bien
moins élevé que le mur d'investissement
ou de dépenses qu'on présente ce sera
pas l'optimal l'optimal c'est la réforme
globale de ma prime renove mais en
parallèle je ne veux pas qu'on attaque
le calendrier des passoirs thmique en
laissant penser qu'une sortie massive de
location se prépare et encore moins
qu'on le ferait au nom des plus fragiles
et des plus modestes parce qu'encore une
fois les plus fragiles et les plus
modestes c'est ceux qui ont le moins de
choix et ce sont les plus précaires d'un
point de vue énergétique et je sais
qu'on se retrouvera
là-dessus chers collègues nous avons une
vingtaine de questions question d'une
minute si vous pouvez faire moins d'une
minute ça laissera le temps à monsieur
le ministre vous apporter des réponses
madame Charlotte goouci
bolognaise merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
ma question porte sur la décarbonation
des mobilités lourdes et notamment de
l'incitation au rétrofit des véhicules
la loi de finance pour 2019 a étendu au
véhicules équipés d'une motorisation
électrique ou à pied à hydrogène le
dispositif de déduction fiscale
exceptionnel déjà en vigueur pour les
véhicules de 3,3 tonnes fonctionnant au
gaz naturel au biométhane ou qui utilise
le carburant
ed95 il semble que ce dispositifs dont
les objectifs fixés tant au niveau
national qu'européen soient efficaces
quels sont les intentions du
gouvernement quant à l'extension de ce
dispositif au poids lourd rétrofité je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
souhaite absolument répondre à toutes
les questions donc il m'a proposé de
changer un peu les règles et qu'il
puisse répondre directement à vos
questions donc monsieur le
ministre d'abord ça me permettra d'être
certain de tenir dans le délai d'une
minute et ça évitera la frustration de
me retrouver à devoir partir à un moment
n'ayant pas répondu à certaines
questions je commence maintenant le
décompte de ma minute pour vous répondre
le rétrofit est un super truc pourquoi
parce qu'il m'évite la totalité de
l'empreinte qui consiste à fabriquer un
camion à partir de rien et donc changer
le moteur présente un intérêt évidemment
c'est un tout petit peu plus compliqué
pour les poids lourds mais il y a
compris quelques questions d'assurance
mais on est absolument convaincu que ça
a un intérêt et dans l'appel à projet
écosystème véhicule lourd porté par
France relance nous soutenons ce
dispositif ça vaut déjà pour les
véhicules particuliers ça vaut pour les
véhicules utilitaires depuis le 1er
janvier de cette année ça vocation
asstente pour les poids lourds passer
cette phase soutien pr de relance dans
le cadre de cet appel à
projet Sophie
panonacle merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre tout d'abord je
souhaite vous remercier pour l'intérêt
que vous portez à mes travaux sur
l'adaptation des politiques forestières
au changement climatique les forêts
françaises souffrent et ne parviennent
pas à remplir correctement leur rôle de
de puit de carbone en interministériel
avec Marc fen ministre de l'Agriculture
vous partager la lourde responsabilité
de poursuivre et de consolider le
soutien apporté à la forêt de restaurer
ce pu de carbone et de péréniser les
forêts diversité diversifié et plus
résiliente un financement inédit dans le
cadre de la planification écologique est
attendu et dans le PLF 2024 les moyens
dédiés à la forêt augmente
substantiellement de 500 millions
d'euros en en autorisation d'engagement
et de 400 millions d'euros en crédit de
paiement 250 millions pour le
renouvellement forestier avec la
plantation d'un millier d'arbres
conformément aux engagements pris par le
président de la République d'ici 2030 et
200 millions d'euros pour le
développement du bois construction et
d'une industrie française compétitive de
transformation du bois monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous confirmer que
2024 sera l'année de nouveaux moyens
contribuant à l'adaptation des forêts au
changement climatiques merci merci
Monsieur le Ministre
oui je peux vous le confirmer 50
millions d'euros d'abord et j'insiste
là-dessus parce qu'ils ont été mis sur
le budget
2023 pour le PEPR sur l'adaptation de la
forêt au changement climatique
c'est-à-dire un programme de recherche
inédit sur quel type d'essence à planter
parce que si on se concentre tout de
suite sur le cahier des charges et sur
les sommes on passe à côté de se
demander ce dont on aura besoin dans
plein de domaines on peut ironiser sur
l'humilité avec laquelle on devrait
regarder 200 pas dans le domaine des
forêts ce qu'on plante aujourd'hui à
vocation être là à la fin de ce siècle
quand nous aurons des trajectoires de
température qui seront plus fortes tout
la nécessité de le faire dès maintenant
et de le faire de manière puissante les
crédits que vous avez annoncé sont
exacts ils sont historiques ils sont
partagés entre ministère de
l'Agriculture qui a la responsabilité de
la cviculture et le mien du stockage du
carbone et il y a une dimension
internationale au soutien de la
biodiversité qui n'a paraît pas de
manière directe mais qui vient compléter
ses aides nous gérons ça de manière
étroite les effectifs de l'ONF sont
gérés par le masa mais ils ont également
fait l'objet d'une attention toute
particulière merci Madame marjolen
memilfer merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre merci vraiment de
votre présence de vos explications
toujours très claires et puis de votre
engagement résolu dans la transition
euh moi j'ai une question sur la
planification budgétaire là vraiment on
se rend compte qu'on est enfin à une
maille de la planification vraiment
structurée organisée enfin je veux dire
ça fait plusieurs années que ça se met
en place ça ça se met en route c'est
c'est fantastique mais sur le voyet de
la planification budgétaire on n' pas
encore la même logique de pluriannualité
et on sent qu'il y a de la réticence à
aller sur la pluriannualité budgétaire
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez parce que
nous ça nous semble vraiment une action
indispensable à la structuration des
filières derrière et puis dans la
déclinaison des des copes territoriales
comment vous imaginez qu'on puisse avoir
des une une COP qui soit vraiment
engageante pour les régions comment vous
voyez la coopération des territoires moi
je suis élu en overneuronalpe et il vous
aura pas échappé qu'il y a eu des
annonces sur le retrait du zan sur le
retrait des financement du service
public de l'efficacité énergétique de
l'habitat dans cette région et moi je me
demande comment ils vont se confronter
aux enjeux de la
COP je commence par le début par
définition à partir du momentù on fait
une planification
pluriannuelle l'enjeu de crédibilité
c'est que tout soit plusuréannualisé la
lourdeur de la tâche je je je veux pas
faire pleurer sur les équipes du sgpe
mais si aucun pays avant la France n'a
fait ce ce travail c'est aussi parce
qu'il y a une une intensité dans ce
qu'il y a à conduire et d'ors et déjà
aujourd'hui nous avons des maquettes
région par région d'abord des émissions
à l'instant et des trajectoires qui
pourrai être suivies je n'ai pas changé
d'avis par rapport à la au moment où
j'ai répondu au député Vatin je continue
de penser qu'il faut faire confiance aux
collectivités territorial et donc que
c'est pas à l'état de leur dire à quel
endroit doit faire exactement les
baisses de gisement je reste
foncièrement un élu local dans
l'approche faire confiance simplement
dans le respect de la loi et quand il y
a un texte qui est voté sen extraire
c'est menacer d'illégalité les documents
sur lesquels il repose ne pas appliquer
le zan ça veut dire en fait appliquer un
dispositif plus absurde que celui qui a
été décrié ici à peu près par tout le
monde puisque c'est - 50 % par pour tout
le monde quelle que soit l'intensité des
efforts qui ont été fait en clair c'est
donner plus à ceux qui ont fait le moins
et donner moins à ceux qui ont fait le
plus je ne peux pas croire que des
déclarations d'un dimanche pour faire en
sorte de faire parler de soi aboutissent
à une mise en œuvre effective de ce type
de politique dans
l'avenir merci jeanve
Boni merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre si l'état augmente
de 7 milliards ses dépenses pour la
transition écologique en 2020 24 il
compte aussi sur la mobilisation
d'autres acteurs notamment des
collectivités quel montant attendez-vous
raisonnablement d'elle en 2024 quel
contact avez-vous engagé pour leur faire
accepter cet effort décidé par le seul
gouvernement par quels moyens les
inciterez-vous à augmenter leur
investissement alors que leur épargne a
fondu avec l'inflation et que l'État
leur impose un
désendettement sur le fond vert il
connaîtra une augmentation de 500
millions d'euros fléché vers la
rénovation thermique de 2000 écoles
conformément au souhait du président
Macron pensez-vous que le montant évoqué
250000 € par écolle soit suffisant pour
inciter les communes à solliciter cette
aide et engager les
travaux monsieur le député Boni je vais
faire appel à ce que je sais très
répandu dans le Cantal et et un vrai bon
sens paysan
00 millions de mètres Carr c'est le
nombre de mètres carrés que nous devons
rénover au titre des écoles il y a 43908
écoles en France vous accepterez avec
moi d'arrondir environ 40000 celles qui
doivent être retravaillé puisqu'on
considère qu'il y en a que 10 % qui sont
aujourd'hui au normees ces 50 millions
de mètr carrés en partant des tarifs
moyens que nous avons constaté sur la
rénovation ça fait de l'ordre de 50
milliards d'euros qui sont à engager au
titre du fond vert on a fait une
première vague qui nous permet d'abord
de vérifier ces chiffres puisque ce sont
618 écoles qui ont été accompagné sur
les 6 premiers mois de l'année de
manière volontaire contenu des crédits
qui étaient rendus disponibles ce qui a
représenté 60 18 millions d'euros pour
141 millions d'euros de fond vert si
vous prenez exactement les mêmes ratios
vous vous apercevez que pour être bien
il faut qu'on ajoute au 500 millions
déjà existants dans le cadre du fond
vert qui peuvent servir à la rénovation
ce 500 millions spécifique sur les
écoles 2 milliards de Crès bonifiés du
renve vous multipliez ça pendant 10 ans
et vous avez un rest à charge de la part
des collectivités dont la moitié est
payée par les économies de
fonctionnement je pourrais vous
détailler ça de manière plus précise
qu'est-ce qu'on attend des collectivités
on attend plus de la réorientation de
crédit que des dépenses nouvelles le
fait d'aller faire de la rénovation
plutôt que du neuve dans un certain
nombre de cas de se poser la question de
reconstruire la ville sur elle-même
plutôt que de l'étendre des réflexes qui
ne sont pas des réflexes qui sont
inflationnistes en soi mais qui
consistent à flécher les crédits au bon
endroit et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
d'évoquer ce sujet avec les principales
associations d'élus pour parler de
planification et c'est le sens du Tour
de France que je viens d'entreprendre
une Association des Maires par semaine
une association d'élus par semaine un
débat citoyens par semaine et cette
semaine c'est adcf et Anel merci Pascal
Boer
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre alors que nous avons encore de
nombreux défis à relever pour atteindre
nos objectif en matière d'économie
circulaire qui est une composante
essentielle de la transition écologique
trop souvent oubliée je ne veux que me
féliciter du maintien à 300 millions
d'euros du fond économie circulaire dans
le PLF 2024 et des 100 millions d'euros
en soutien à la filière de valorisation
énergétique des combustibles solides de
récupération même si 150 millions de
euros avait été initialement annoncé par
laadem pour autant le déploiement de
cette filière doit suivre une vision
long terme monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous confirmer que cette
enveloppe budgétaire spécifique au CSR
fera l'objet d'une trajectoire
pluriannuelle je vous
remercie vous avez totalement raison à
la fois sur le fond sur la trajectoire
pluriannuelle et sur la nécessité qu'on
accélère sur l'économie circulaire qui
typiquement là aussi est bonne pour le
climat est bonne pour le pouvoir d'achat
un chiffre 850 millions de tonnes c'est
ce que nous consommons collectivement
nous tous français la part de ce qui est
recyclé de deuxè main dans ces 850
millions de tonnes c'était 17,6 % en
2017 on a réussi à faire progresser ce
chiffre de 0,5 % par an mais nous ne
sommes que à un peu plus de 20 % et donc
avec des marges la nécessité qu'il y a
euh
à accélérer est une est une nécessité et
j'aurai l'occasion la semaine prochaine
à l'occasion de la journée de la
réparation qui tombe le 20 octobre de
préciser comment dans le cadre des bonus
réparation nous continuons de pousser
dans un certain nombre de domaines vous
m'avez interrogé sur les CSR ils sont
édables jusqu'en 2026 mais avec un
encadrement qui se fait à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne sur ce qui est
possible et sur ce qui ne l''est pas une
date limite de toute façon à ce
moment-là merci la parole est à Claire
Colomb pitola
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
merci Monsieur le le ministre au cours
des derniers mois il y a eu une
concertation menée sur la mise en place
d'un système de consigne je vais
raccourcir ma
question vous avez annoncé lors des
Assises des déchets que la situation
n'était pas propice à la mise en place
d'un système de consigne mais plutôt à
la mise en place d'autres leviers comme
la généralisation de la tarification
incitative nous sommes conscients que
vous mettez tout en œuvre pour améliorer
la collecte et le recyclage et que votre
engagement est total pouvez-vous nous
indiquer monsieur le ministre comment
vous prévoyez d'adapter le cadre de la
réglementation en cadrant la
tarification
inicitative afin qu'elle puisse être
généralisée et quels objectif de
collecte vous projetz notamment pour les
bouteilles plastiques et de recyclage de
plastique enfin concernant le réemploi
prévoyez-vous également le même type de
mesure je vous remercie c'est une
question complexe mais c'est important
merci bon question complexe nous sommes
en moyenne à 62 % de recyclage de nos
bouteilles de plastique et nous avons
signé des des engagements avec l'Europe
qui doivent nous nous permettre d'être à
90 % en 2029 et à 77 % en 2027 il y a un
risque qu'tiennent pas ces objectif vu
de l'extérieur on dit regardez tous les
pay où il y a la consigne sont meilleurs
que vous sauf que la vérité c'est qu'on
a des disparités considérables dans ce
pays avec des collectivités
territoriales qui sont déjà à 90 % et
d'autres qui sont à 40 que moi
généraliser un dispositif qui va
consister là où des collectivités
locales ont investi dépenser de l'argent
mis en place des dispositifs de collecte
me pose une difficulté ces dispositifs
de colleèg vont être installés dans les
supermarchés ils vont poser des
difficultés aux petits commerces qui
font partie de ceux qui considèrent que
c'est une fausse bonne idée ils vont
globalement bénéficier aux villes dans
un contexte où aujourd'hui les bons
élèves ce sont les ruraux des quantités
de domaines où on les pointe du doigt
dans ce domaine en matière de recyclage
je vais vous dire il y a pas photos sur
les niveaux de performance et dans les
villes qui sont les plus mauvaises il y
a Grenoble il y a Paris et il y a des
villes dont il est contreintuitif de
lire les noms comment est-ce qu'on va
faire assez simplement d'abord
l'objectif c'est pas de plus recycler
l'objectif c'est de moins consommer de
plastique le problème des pays qui ont
mis en place une consigne c'est que ça
maintient une forme de dépendance à ce
plastique qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va
rendre possible la tarification
incitative mixte parce qu'on sait qu'il
y a des difficultés pour le mettre en
place en ville il me semble qu'il y a un
amendement qui sera déposé par voie
parlementaire pour rendre possible le
fait qu'à l'intérieur d'un même
territoire on puisse avoir les deux
types de dispositifs ça fait partie des
préconisations de l'ADEM on va aider
pour le hors domicile en mettant en
place des collectes pardon des poubelles
sélectives dans l'espace public on va
faire en sorte aussi dans le cadre de la
repe emballage de durcir les coût pour
les plus petites bouteilles en plastique
qui sont celles qu'on collecte le moins
et pour faire en sorte d'aller vers une
baisse d'étonnage et à la fin les
collectivités qui sont très en retard
sur les objectifs elles paieront un
malus notre pays pe 1,3 milliard d'euros
au titre de son mauvais taux de collecte
dans ce 1illard3 800 millions concerne
la part liée au ménage il n'est n'est
pas normal qu'un habitant de vezou qui
via sa taxe d'enlèvement des ordures
ménagères et son comportement citoyen
est à 90 % de recyclage paye pour
l'habitant de Marseille qui ne fait pas
cet effort une deuxième fois et donc il
sera logique qu'on mette en place un
dispositif de
responsabilité Marseille éta un hasard
madame Marseille ou ailleurs n'est-ce
pas la parole est à Daniel
brûlebois merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre avec ch collèguue
nous avons consigné le courrier de
Laurent sédel dans lequel nous vous
demandons de ne pas oublier la ruralité
où la transition écologique doit être
certes radicale mais concrète adapté et
profondément juste vous l'avez dit les
ruraux sont des bons élèves souvent les
meilleurs donc comment pensez-vous
articuler le plan rénovation le plan
transition écologique de 7 milliards
d'euros avec les plans existants déjà
plan haut plan ruralité plan France
ruralité fond vert et pouvez-vous nous
donner des précis prcision sur la leur
déclinaison financière pour les
territoires ruraux dans le cadre de la
du PLF
2024 votre micro chers collègue c'est
bon d'abord je compte procéder par le
dialogue c'était la raison de ma
présence à l'pp Dua au congrès de la
mrrf il y a quelques jours notamment
pour échanger avec l'association des mes
eurau sur ce sujet de en conservant un
dispositif dans lequel ce sont pas des
appels à projet ou des appels à
manifestation d'intérêt qui permettent
aux grosses collectivités ayant beaucoup
de moyens d'obtenir le maximum de
subvention tris en faisant en sorte
d'intégrer dans les mécanismes de
financement c'est le cas avec les
aménités rurales un dispositif qui
tiennent compte des espaces et pas
seulement des habitants 4 en déclinant
la territorialisation pour regarder les
objectifs dans lesquels de manière plus
spontanée les ruraux vont s'intégrer 5
en examinant dispositif par dispositif
la contribution de chacun je pense à
l'abaississement des seuils pour la
petite hydroélectricité que nousons que
nous avons évoqué il y a seulement
quelques heures et à la façon dont dans
un certain nombre de domaines il faut
qu'on soit capable au contraire
d'écouter y compris les solutions qui
viennent de ces territoires et pas
imaginer que c'est nous qui allons les
imaginer pour
eux la parole est à hugette
tigna merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement a
mis en place le plan cyclot logistique
en 2021 et les aides étaient réservées
aux
véhicules vélo VAE et vélo cargo et non
au trip électrique parce qu'à l'époque
il n'existait pas de triporte électrique
donc je suis ravie de vous dire que dans
ma circonscription il y a une entreprise
innovante motowat qui fait des
triporteurs électriques et qu'on
souhaite qu'on puisse étendre ses aides
à ce type de véhicule ma question qui
n'a rien à voir est très
rapide quelle est la position de la
France par rapport au règlement
packaging qui est en train d'être
discuté en ce moment à
Bruxelles
le règlement packaging
ppwr HM ah le ppw j'ai cru que vous me
parliez du ppwx et c'est pour ça que
l'espace d'instant non pour être clair
c'est sur les emballages en vrac
bon la position de la France c'est que
le fait que l'Europe nous explique
qu'elle a besoin de temps pour imaginer
un dispositif qui nous contraindrait
nous à mettre sur pause un dispositif
pour faire en sorte de limiter le
plastique à usage unique n'est pas
vraiment une position qui nous convient
et pas plus tard que lundi prochain au
Luxembourg ça fait à nouveau partie des
sujets que je vais évoquer avec mes
homologues européens on pense que dans
un certain de domaines il faut aller
vers une solution européenne mais que
dans d'autres quand des pays ont
commencé à agir on peut pas leur
demander de mettre sur pause de façon
trop brutale y compris par rapport aux
investissements qui ont été faits par un
certain nombre de secteurs pour
s'équiper et pour tenir compte des
législations
existantes la parole est au député
Marchot merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre l'incitation aux
efforts pour arriver à des pratiques
plus vertueuses et nécessaires mais il y
a des cas dans lesquels l'absurdité au
nom de l'écologie fait loi dans le Nord
une voie de covoturage a été activé sur
l'1 en cas de trafic dense et le moins
qu'on le puisse dire c'est que ce n'est
pas un Fran succès une expérimentation
coûteuse 9 million d'euros 1,5 million
uniquement pour l'aménagement de la voie
avec des caméras thermiques et des
appareils photo compliqué mal respecté
et potentiellement cause d'accident
l'expérimentation entre un peu dans une
nouvelle phase celle des contrôle et
celle des amendes 135 € les gens du
douisi chez moi qui sont obligés de
prendre la voiture pour aller bosser ils
ne le font pas par plaisir monsieur le
ministre avec un litre approchant les 2
€ avec vous c'est de l'écologie oui mais
de l'écologie punitive encore un peu
plus on taxe les gens alors Monsieur le
Ministre comment et quand allez-vous
vous assurer que les crédits alloué à la
transition écologique et énergétique
seront utilisé à bonne
tion
monsieur le député je je vous avoue très
simpblement que je ne connais pas cette
portion de LA1 et la réalité de ce
citurage et ni même puisque vous faites
manifestement référence à une partie
autoroutière sur le fait de savoir dans
quelle mesure elle a été aidée par des
crédits budgétaires où elle s'inscrit au
contraire dans un autre type de
dispositif ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que votre discours est un plédoyer
vibrant pour accélérer sur la voiture
électrique surtout dans un contexte où
si vraiment vous venez de ce secteur
vous savez à quel point les gig Factory
qui sont en train de se construire pour
permettre
euh toute la partie de la construction
électrique permettre d'éviter ce fameux
litre à 2 € que vous évoquiez un peu
plus tôt et faire en sorte en terme de
pouvoir d'achat que les choses puissent
bouger moi je vais vous dire un mot du
covoitureage parce que vous prenez le
petit bout de la lorniette qui est si je
comprends bien à la fois la dépense d'un
million et demi d'euros et
accessoirement l'amand pour celui qui ne
respecte pas non pas le fait de pas
faire du covoiturage mais de pas faire
du coiturage dans une voie dédié au
covoiturage qui sert à faire une
expérimentation ce qui n'est pas
exactement la même chose vous
conviendrez avec moi que les États-Unis
ne sont ni un pays communiste ni un pays
tenté par une forme d'insoumission et
pourtant là-bas il y a depuis très
longtemps des voies qui sont réservées
au
covoiturage que ce soit pas votre modèle
c'est votre droit le plus strict il
n'empêche que je vous dis que dans la
manière parfois beaucoup trop
nationaliste don vous regardez les
choses faire un peu de benchmark et
regarder ce qui se passe ailleurs c'est
à la fois une forme d'humilité et il y a
parfois des exemples à prendre le
meilleur moyen d'économiser et de
l'argent et des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre c'est aussi de regarder dans
quelle mesure on peut être en capacité
dans des voitures existantes qu'on a pas
besoin de changer de partager des trajet
le covoiturage est un des leviers c'est
pas le seul mais c'est un levier et
c'est un levier crédible que nous ayons
90 % des gens qui aillent travailler qu'
soient seul dans leur voiture c'est une
perte et d'énergie et de
moyens la parole est à Emmanuel blerry
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre j'aimerais faire focus sur
le fond vert s'il vous plaît euh
effectivement 20 % d'augmentation très
bien euh mon rôle aussi c'est d'amener
les problématiques dans les territoires
hein donc là je parle du pas de calis de
ma circonscription la première je
remonte certaines informations de nos
maires en l'occurrence Monsieur le Maire
d'et qui m'expliiquait effectivement la
difficulté pour avoir de la lisibilité
sur le le fond vert en tout cas pour
recevoir les les subventions donc par
exemple dans le padcad actuellement
l'enveloppe est vide euh mais malgré
tout on peut inscrire les les les
dossiers jusqu'au 31 décembre
20223 il se pose la question puisque
vous savez il manque d'ingénierie c'est
chronophage de de faire ces dossiers
est-ce qu'il va devoir effectivement
renouveler son son dossier pour la le
2024 ou est-ce que celui de 2023 sera
pris en compte qu'est-ce que je veux
dire à travers ça c'est qu'effectivement
faut accompagner tout ça dans les
territoires avec beaucoup plus de de
lisibilité pour nos élus et ça leur
donner effectivement de la visibilité
pour pour leur projet en la matière
merci Monsieur le
Ministre merci monsieur le député pour
pour cette question le hasard fait bien
les choses puisque j'ai été dans le pas
decalais à aras à longnness à moule et
dans quelques autres endroits la semaine
dernière et à isbec
euh la réponse est oui les sommes qui
sont pardon les dossiers qui sont
déposés en 2023 on va pas demander aux
gens de les refaire pour 2024 la passion
de la paperasserie ne va pas jusque là
et on a voulu depuis début que ce
dispositif soit simple et que justement
on évite des appels à projets pour que
les plus petites communes puissent en
bénéficier et vous verrez quand vous
verrez les chiffres nationaux que ça
fonctionne ce ne sont pas les plus
grosses collectivités qui ont capté les
crédits du fond ça dépend des lignes il
y a évidemment des lignes sur lequell la
nature par exemple pour la rénovation
électrique c'est plus souvent
l'intercommunalité qu' la compétence ou
le syndicat intercommunal que la commune
proprement dit mais globalement on a
tenu cet objectif on va continuer à le
faire et la partie ingééie on continue à
réfléchir et on continue aussi à se
demander comment mieux associer les
parlementaire au suivi au traitement des
dossiers parce qu'on a des questions qui
nous remontent en disant faut pas que ce
soit le préfet seul dans son bureau qui
fasse l'arbitrage avec le
maire très important monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Sylvain
carrière merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre dans le projet de
loi finan vous dites inciter les
collectivités à verdir leur
investissement et orienter massivement
ceci en faveur de la transition
écologique pourtant dans le département
de l'héro où je suis élu et particulier
dans la ville de 7 il en est autrement
et vous le savez car je vous ai
interpellé à de multiples reprises déjà
sur le sujet à défaut de verdir les
mobilité la mairie construit des
parkings supplémentaires en plein cœur
de ville pour un montant de plus de 12
millions d'euros des arrachages d'arbres
des embouteillages à outrance pas de
mobilité alternative à la voiture
individuelle et selon de nouveaux
éléments un impact sur l'quifère sous
évalué le collectif citoyen de ban
public qui lutte contre le parking
alerte depuis des années sur les
nombreux manquements dans ce dossier par
conséqu monsieur le ministre comment
garantir dans ce PLF que les dotations
de l'État servent bien à la transition
écologique aussi pouvez-vous faire la
lumière sur la situation à 7 qui est
aujourd'hui source de grande tension je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le député pour
pour votre question c'est toujours
extrêmement compliqué quand on descend à
l'échelle d'un projet plus l'échelle est
petite plus le risque de porter une
parole définitive sur le plan national
en nayant pas tous les éléments est
grand les éléments qui m'avaient été
transmis il y a quelques mois y compris
sur les transplantations d'arbres de
manière à éviter de les couper si on
parle bien du même sujet la façon dont
ça dégageait des espaces sur l'espace
public par ailleurs pour permettre des
élargissements de trottoir ou de pistes
cyclables j'avoue que cette histoire
d'aquifè je la découvre dans vos propos
donc il y a des éléments qui me manquent
tout l'enjeu c'est de faire confiance
aux agents de l'État qui dans les
territoires ont une proximité avec les
projets pour être capable de les mesurer
mais tous les projets font pas l'objet
d'un accompagnement du fond vert et le
fond vert n'est pas un label pour dire
tout est parfait écologiquement on sait
qu'on est dans une transition dans
lequel et vous le savez vous-même on est
parfois aussi obligé de prendre en
compte la dimension sociale et pas
seulement la dimension écologique comme
quand beaucoup d'entre vous vous avez
souhaité qu'on puisse aider les gens à
remplir leur chaudière de fioul malgré
les conséquences que ça peut avoir pour
le réchauffement climatique il y a à peu
près un an donc être capable de mesurer
ce qui relève de l'ordre de la
transition et ce qui relève de l'ordre
de l'évolution et de la lutte contre les
règlements climatiques c'est un
mouvement que nous devons faire en
regardant les deux en même temps il y
aura pas plus de voiture dans notre
perspective il n'y aura plus voiture
thermique un jour mais on conservera des
véhicules permettant lesmobilités
individuelle la parole est à Vincent
decur merci je souhaite profiter de
votre présence monsieur le ministre pour
attirer votre
attention sur le biopropane qui a fait
l'objet d'un amendement que j'ai porté
avec plusieurs collègues qui propose de
l'exonéré de ticp PE et qui a été adopté
par notre commission lundi soir euh
produit à partir de déchets industriels
recyclés et d'huile végétale le
biopropane présente de bien meilleures
performances environnementales que le
propane traditionnel et surtout un un
bien moindre facteur d'émission cette
proposition a pour objectif
d'accompagner la transition énergétique
et la décarbonation de quelques 150000
TPE et PME implanté dans 25000 communes
rurales en marge des aut gaz naturel
alors j'aimerais recueillir votre avis
sur cette proposition même si vous
pourriez tenter de réserver cette
réponse à Madame panier ruinaché je le
comprendrai mais en fait cette question
rejoint celle de ma collègue Daniel
brûlebois sur la manière d'accompagner
spécifiquement la transition écologique
dans le cas présent la transition
énergétique en milieu
rural quand un agrégé de biologie me
pose une question sur le biopropane et
qu'en plus il me propose à la fin une
porte de sortie pour ne pas avoir
répondre j'ai envie de prendre la porte
de sortie l'amitié que je vous porte non
non l'amitié que que je vous porte et et
les années que nous avons passé ensemble
à occuper des fonctions d'administration
départementale dans des territoires
différents me pous juste à vous répondre
quelque
chose on aura besoin de beaucoup de
sources d'énergie pour réussir cette
transition écologique et on pourra pas
se priver du biogaz on aura besoin de
s'appuyer sur ces énergies biogaz et il
faut qu'on laisse parfois des
neutralités technologiques à la en terme
d'innovation et d'accompagnement des
projets donc je transmettrai de manière
plus approfondie à nipierch mais je peux
vous assurer que je suis convaincu qu'on
y arrivera pas00 on le voit que ce soit
pour les crêtes pour les chaudières
biomasse que ce soit pour les
accompagnements pour les filières
industrielles et en plus ce sont des
énergies de proximité qui peuvent être
utilisées dans le cadre de circuit court
et qui peuvent répondre à des
problématiques en particulier pour des
engins spéciaux au milieu rural pierre
Vatin toujours merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre oui tout
à l'heure j'ai soufflé le froid à telle
enseigne que le président zulésis en est
ému cette fois-ci je va demander de nous
rassurer j'ai été saisi par la filière
poil à bois Pelé sur leur crainte de
voir les la prime réuve réservée au
projets de rénovation globale et pas au
projet de petite rénovation et donc je
vous serai reconnaissant de les rassurer
sur ce sujet-là les ménages modestes ne
peuvent pas nécessairement entreprendre
des rénovations GL u de leur
coût je vais vous rassurer nous
continuons à penser qu'il y aura des
rénovations qui ne seront pas globales y
compris parce que si on dit aux gens
c'est tout ou rien le nombre de ceux qui
ne feront rien sera important mais il y
a des monogestes qu'on ne veut pas voir
je vais être précis
ambition 700000 performance 200000
efficace 500000 dans les efficaces il y
a par exemple le fait d'installer du
chauffage bois en
revanche quelqu'un qui a une chir fuel
et qui demanderait d'aller financer un
monogeste ça nous poserait une
difficulté on souhaite que le monogeste
ne se fasse pas en alternative à un
changement de vecteur en
clair si le monogeste c'est d'installer
un poil à Blois c'est possible si le
monogeste c'est de garder une chaudière
fossile et seulement d'aller changer les
fenêtres là on souhaite qu'il y ait plus
d'ambition pour que les choses aient
lieu donc la filière vous pouvez la
rassurer très fortement
la parole est à Madame Christelle pétex
lev président monsieur le ministre les
réformes des redevances sur l'eau
continuent avec l'objectif louable
qu'elle pèse moins sur les particuliers
et plus sur une logique pollueur payeur
si nous saluons la décision de relever
enfin le plafond mordant des recettes de
l'Agence des agences de l'eau nous nous
interrogeons tout fois sur la
destination finale de ces fonds que
collecteront notamment les collectivités
au titre des redevances sur la
performance des réseaux d'eau et
d'assaainissement ces financements
seront-ils destinés à l'entretien des
réseaux qui ne reçoit qu'un tiers des
fonds aujourd'hui collecté par les
agences ou continueront-ils d'alimenter
l'ofb comme le laisse entendre l'article
28 une subvention directe de l'État ne
serait-elle pas préférable à ce vicieux
principe l'eau paye pour l'eau et la
biodiversité au détriment de la
réhabilitation des réseaux je vous
remercie c'est une question
particulièrement
pertinente d'abord je veux vous
rassurer dans les moyens nouveaux qui
vont être accordés aux agences de l'eau
il n'y aura pas de complément de crédit
pour l'ofb au titre du financement de la
biodiversité ce que vous lisez sans
doute dans l'article 18 c'est qu'il y a
35 millions d'euros sur les
475 qui vont servir de cofinancement
pour l'outreem or le moyen d'aller
financer ses travaux outreem au titre de
l'eau passe par l'ofb mais ça n'est pas
une contribution au titre de la
politique de biodiversité comme les
presque 500 millions d'euros qui sont à
l'heure actuelle dans le schéma des
dépenses et pour avoir passé un moment
avec les comités les présidents des
comités de bassin ils sont très au clair
sur le sujet donc je vous confirme on
est exactement dans ce que vous décrivez
une augmentation de la redevance pour
pollution diffuse le fait de mettre à
contribution les énergéticiens dans le
financement global alors qu'aujourd'hui
il bénéficie d'une partie des
prélèvement mais qui ne participe pas au
financement et le fait ensuite d'avoir
un dispositif qui tienne compte des
niveaux de performance mais pour que cet
argent reste dans les collectivités et
accompagne y compris des politiques de
conversion sur les points de captage
pour que la question de la qualité et
pas seulement de la sobriété et de la
quantité soit prise en
compte la parole est à Nicolas
Ray merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre vous le savez la France
manque d'unités de valorisation
énergétique ces unités alimentent les
réseaux de chaleur grâce à la combustion
des déchets notamment les déchets
résiduels il renforce notre souveraineté
énergétique il permettent aussi de
limiter le REC cours à l'enfouissement
cependant on évalue à 6 milliards
d'euros l'investissement nécessaire pour
développer cette filière ma question
seriez-vous favorable à une réfaction de
la TGAP pour ses installations notamment
celle d'au moins 50 % de l'énergie
produite et de l'énergie thermique cette
réfction serait effectivement une
incitation pour les collectivités
d'investir dans les réseaux de chaleur
alimentés par des énergies renouvelables
ou des énergies de
récupération et bien écoutez c'est la
limite de la stratégie qui consiste à
vous répondre sans m'appuyer sur mes
collaborateurs en répondant dans la
foulée immédiate des questions qui sont
posées c'est que je ne sais pas répondre
à cette question
euh bon donc je vais être précis dans ce
que je vais vous dire on a un sujet
effectivement à la fois sur le nombre de
ces uve et sur le développement des
réseaux de chaleur mais le mécanisme que
vous suggérez qui consisterait à revenir
sur la trajectoire de TGAP qui est
particulièrement sévère pour les
enfouissements ce qui est évidemment
souhaitable pour des raisons écologiques
mais qui n'est pas sans impact pour les
uve va nécessiter que je prenne tout
petit peu de temps pour ne pas vous
faire une réponse langue de
bois la parole est à berttin
petit oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voudrais revenir
sur ma prime Renov ça a été évoqué par
certains collègues parlementaires et par
vous-même monsieur le ministre alors
loin de moi l'idée de remettre en cause
le dispositif hein il a démontré toute
son utilité sa pertinence si j'en juge
par son niveau de mobilisation mais par
contre si vous voulez il se passe pas
une semaine sans que dans ma
circonscription et au cabinet
parlementaire je soit saisi de demande
émanant de nos concitoyens souvent des
des ménages à faies ressources qui
attendent le versement de la prime qui
ont un problème pour joindre les
services le dossier est à refaire parce
qu'il a été égaré qui ne sont pas
forcément très habile avec la
dématérialisation et une erreur ben leur
demande est annulée il faut recommencer
enfin voilà ce genre de
dysfonctionnement qui agace au plus haut
point nos nos administrés et alors vous
avez dit que vous croyez au vertuus de
la décentr réalisation de la con la
déconcentration je vous suis totalement
sur ce sujet le temps que ça se met en
place qu'est-ce qu'on répond à à ces
personnes encore une fois qui qui
attendent le versement des primes et qui
sont complètement
dépourvus demain à Lille
Lana réunit l'ensemble de son réseau la
question des délais elle se pose vous
vous signalez qu'il y a la question des
délais pour les gens il y a aussi
parfois la question des délais pour les
entreprises si j' objective les choses
ça représente des milliers de cas mais
sur des centaines de milliers les
indicateurs que nous avons montrent
qu'on a une situation qui s'est
améliorer mais quand vous avez
25000 difficultés même sur 700000
n'empêche que ça fait 25000 et rapporté
à vos circonscriptions il est logique
que vous ayez des cas de ce type un des
objectifs de la réforme dans la fluidité
dans ce qui sera présenté demain c'est
précisément de faire en sorte d'éviter
de nous retrouver avec ces difficultés
qui du coup alimentent un mauvais bouche
à oreille sur le dis posositif et freine
les gens parce que une expérience
malheureuse conduit ensuite un ménage à
se dire mais si j'ai la même mes
aventures est-ce queil faut que je me
lance dans le dispositif donc on est sur
quelque chose
de de souhaitable bon pour la planète
bon pour le pouvoir d'achat y compris
pour des petits propriétaires qui
peuvent remettre des des logements qui
sont aujourd'hui hors service sur le
marché on a besoin d'améliorer le
dispositif ça n'est pas une question
triviale c'est au cœur de notre
réflexion sur l'évolution à compter du
1er janvier janvier prochain de ma
primeren
madame
bouo merci monsieur le Président de me
laisser poser ma question monsieur le
ministre al je vais vous parler d'une de
mes marottes je commence par une
citation qui vient du document qui
s'appelle le financement de la Stratégie
nationale pour la biodiversité cette
citation elle dit le système fiscal dans
son ensemble tend à encourager les
pressions sur la biodiversité notamment
l'artificialisation des sols lorsque
nous avons étudié la proposition de loi
pour mettre en œuvre le zan en juin
dernier vous avez dressé un constat
similaire et là c'est vous que je cite
il faut qu'on puisse utiliser une sorte
de surtaxe au moment de
l'artificialisation qui permette
d'abonder un fond friche il faut que la
fiscalité accompagne le mouvement sur
lequel nous nous trouvons vous avez
aussi défendu qu'il fallait encourager
dès à présent les collectivités à
renaturer et nous partageons ces
objectifs pourtant le PLF 2024 n'est
toujours pas à la hauteur alors mon
groupe le groupe écologiste porte à ce
sujet de nombreux amendements dans ce
PLF pour réduire la fiscalité sur les
espaces naturels renforcer celle sur
l'artificialisation financer la
renaturation qui reste extrêmement
coûteuse favoriser les communes qui
artificialisent peu auquel d'entre eux
le gouvernement compte-il donner un avis
favorable
1 je me réjouis de vous retrouver et je
me souviens que vous nous aviez quitté
pour le vote pour un heureux événement
dont j'ai cru comprendre qu'il était
arrivé vous me permettrez de m'en
réjouir
2 euh je n'ai évidemment pas oublié mes
propos et l'idée c'est de faire en sorte
de passer d'un régime qui aujourd'hui
conc concerne un peu moins de 7000
communes qui ont mis en place une sur
Taxe quand il y a des plusvalues qui
sont importantes sur de
l'artificialisation auquel s'ajoute un
bout de taxe nationale qui est reffléché
vers les jeunes agriculteurs pour
l'essentiel c'est de pouvoir avoir un
dispositif de ce type qui soit
généralisé avec des taux qui soient plus
élevés j'ai souhaité qu'il puisse avoir
plutôt une forme de coconstruction
législative je ne sais pas si vous avez
vous-même imaginé un dispositif ce que
je sais c'est que avec le président zou
nous avons il y a quelques jours un de
travail sur les formes que ça pourrait
prendre il y a une limite madame bouo
par rapport au propos que j'ai pu tenir
et ça va me permettre de finir de
répondre à Madame
pétex c'est que je pense qu'une partie
du produit devrait être affectée aux
agences de l'eau puisque les
conséquences de l'artificialisation
c'est de boucher les nappes et c'est de
poser des difficultés en terme
d'écoulement et que si la recette ne va
que dans la poche de la commune le
risque c'est que pour des raisons
budgétaires vous vous retrouviez avec un
intérêt objectif à artificialiser plutôt
qu'à renaturer ça c'est le petit point
par rapport à la discussion qu'on a vu
dans l'émicy il y a quelques mois où
commission de je suis intimement
convaincu et c'est là-dessus que je
m'arrêterai euh que même si tout n'est
pas parfait dans les 2 milliards et demi
de fond vert il y a un niveau de fond
friche qui est particulièrement élevé
qu'on peut estimer aux alentours de 450
millions d'euros pour l'année qui arrive
c'est 50 % de plus que la moyenne de ce
qu'on a fait au moment du plan de
relance avec là aussi des premiers
chiffres qui sont très encourageants et
spectaculaires plus dans certains
territoire que dans d'autres c'est pas
la fin de l'histoire mais il y avait
rien il y a 4 ans
là-dessus
la parole est à Anne Cécile
violent merci monsieur le Président je
crois que vous avez déjà répondu en
partie va y avoir une modification de ma
prime rve parce qu'on est effectivement
sollicité en ce moment par différents
syndicats et en l'occurrence c'était sur
la question des fenêtres aujourd'hui les
fenêtres en fait la prime ne revient que
sur un changement à partir de fenêtres
simple vitrage et lorsqu'on veut changer
de de fenêtre pour avoir encore une
meilleure isolation une meilleure
performance et bien ce n'est pas
possible si on était déjà passé dans les
années 2000 par exemple à du double
vitrage idem pour les fenêtres de toit
qui permettent quand même une bien
meilleure isolation donc voilà est-ce
que c'est des choses qui sont prévues
effectivement d'être modifié merci
Monsieur le
Ministre j'aimerais là aussi madame
violent vous remercier parce que je
prends la précision de cette question
comme
étant une marque de confiance sur le
fait que je serai sans doute capable de
répondre au fait de savoir si
l'évolution des fenêtres de toit en
l'espace de moins de 20 doit faire
l'objet d'une évolution dans le cadre de
la grille globale de l'évolution de ma
prime ROV et je vais vous décevoir je
n'ai pas ce degré de précision en ma
possession cont tenu de la variété des
des sujets qui m'arrivent de traiter
mais on va faire en sorte de de vous
répondre de manière précise je le redis
la philosophie globale c'est d'essayer
d'aller vers quelque chose qui soit
lisible et qui soit simple avec des
points d'accueil physique qui soi
multipliés parce que typiquement le
simple fait qu'on ait cette discussion
par rapport à un dispositif nécessite
que quelqu'un un puisse immédiatement
trouver l'info pour aller vers du
performant et vous pourrez vous tourner
vers votre voisine qui a commis
effectivement avec Jean-Louis briikou il
y a quelques jours et Julie laornness un
rapport sur le sujet l'accélération elle
pose aussi par des changements
systémiques davantage de recours à
l'humain davantage d'ambition à court
terme sur la manière dont on peut
avancer et un changement dans la
philosophie
globale merci à vous et enfin la 20e
question cher collègue de notre collègue
Vincent
thbo merci monsieur le président
Jean-Marc
zuli monsieur le ministre euh déjà je
salue effectivement les les les
ambitions de de de ce budget malgré tout
ce qui peut être dit et moi il y a un
point qui me m'importe qui est important
c'est notamment les évolutions et
l'accompagnement des collectivités
territoriales et on peut se saluer
effectivement des chiffres annoncés
notamment une augmentation de la DGF de
plus de 200 millions 2è année
consécutive qu'elle augmente alors ça
fait 13 ans qu'elle est pas augmenté on
peut qu' s' féliciter le passage don
frond vert 2li 5 les 100 millions sur
France réalité toutefois vous savez
qu'il y a un point de sensibilité sur
lequel j'ai c'est effectivement la
capacité aujourd'hui au collectivité de
pouvoir prédéfinir les projets et de
même définir quel est leur propre plan
de mise en œuvre notamment dans
différents projets en faveur de la
transition écologique sur ce sujet là
vous voyez bien où je vais en venir je
vais vous parler d'ingénierie locale et
vous le savez que j'ai notamment
consigné une tribune de la NPP sur 100 %
ingénierie on nous avons pu rencontrer
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui envisagé
justement pour accompagnie les
collectivités territorial en terme
d'ingéerie justement pour les aider
aussi à innover juste en complément
monsieur dragon si vous voulez terminer
puisque vous aviez encore une question
je vous en prie terminz au moins comme
ça monsieur le ministre peut conclure
d'accord et bien écoutez je vous
remercie monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre alors je une petite
parenthèse pour pour vous dire que comme
vous ne souhaitez pas revenir à ce que
j'entends ni au charbon ni au fioule je
ne crois pas avoir manqué à mon propos
tout à l'heure la transition écologique
passe aussi par la transition
énergétique et peut-être que vous auriez
dû être accompagné de madame
panierunché je ferme la parenthèse pour
faire très court je suis élu aussi
conseil municipal dans la ville de l'an
dans l'aine nous avions à l'an un
système de transport parcâ en site
propre aérien qui a été stoppé il y a
quelques années euh transport je l'ai
défendu pendant des années il manque
cruellement au Lanois puisque nous avons
une différence de topographie sur la
ville de LAN et ma question est simple
la municipalité a fait le choix
d'arrêter ce système elle se met en tête
maintenant de vouloir retirer toute
l'installation qui a coûté des millions
d'euros au contribuable et je voudrais
avoir votre position si vous acceptez
l'idée même de faire disparaître ou de
transformer une installation comme
celle-là dont certaines villes se
dottent d'ailleurs actuellement à grand
renfort eff for budjétaire je vous
remercie il faut juste couper le micro
merci bon deux questions qui concernent
les collectivités local de manière
différente une sur est-ce qu'on peut les
aider à être éclairé dans les décisions
qu' qu'elles peuvent prendre et l'autre
qui consiste à demander si l'Étap les
empêcher de prendre certaines décisions
je commence par la première en disant
que c'est précisément un des objets de
la territorialisation de la planif cette
partie de soutien et d'appui elle est
cruciale elle va prendre deux formes
d'abord 100 postes un par préfecture
pressemblement plutôt basé dans les
sous-préfectures pour aider les
ruralités et les territoires dans
lesquels il y a déjà un déficite
d'ingénierie propre et ensuite la
formalisation du réseau anct serema Adem
en terme de mise à disposition et la
clarification de la part des subventions
utilisables pour faire en sorte de
lancer le
dispositif ça c'est pour vous monsieur
thbau pour vous monsieur dragon euh je
connais là aussi je vous prie de m'
excuser je ne connais pas ce ce système
de transport et et son
histoire je suis toujours dans une
situation
où le point commun de tous ceux qui sont
dans cette pièce c'est que vous avez
réussi à convaincre des électeurs donc
vous pouvez pas totalement douter de la
démocratie puisqu'elle a permis à des
gens de reconnaître vos qualités au nom
de quoi ceux qui ont fait ce choix
éclairé vous concernant n'auraient pas
fait des choix éclairés concernant les
élus locaux qui ont pris la décision de
changer le mode de transport qui
s'applique dans la ville de l'an et il y
a une forme de prétenion dans le fait de
considérer qu'on aurait une légitimité
nationale qui pourrait écraser des
décisions locales dans la plupart des
cas donc je suis par principe plutôt
attaché au respect d'une liberté locale
je reconnais que ma réponse n'est pas
géolocalisé mais au moins elle a le
mérite de vous dire ce que sont mes
principes merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci pour vos réponses chers collègues
nous nous retrouvons mardi 17 octobre
dans cette même salle pour l'audition de
clémentbonne merci cher collègues